good morning everyone
and can i welcome you to this committee
of development control committee a
of mid software district council may i
first of all remind you of some of the
domestic arrangements for today
please can i ask you ensure that your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
and members are reminded not to use the
messaging chat function during the
meeting unless it is to report a
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interests
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open
i.e teams chats and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application you should bring this to the
attention of our legal advisors please
can you also note that if you are
attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave the meeting
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by myself as the chair
of the meeting
by using the hands up function and we
also
today be using the electronic voting
system for this meeting
if you're experiencing any poor
connection issues in the first instance
please turn your camera off if this
doesn't
work please turn off all incoming video
these options can be found under the
three dots
which is the fourth item along at the
top of the page
uh which is the main information bar can
i also
remind everyone present this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to having been recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
just like to run through a few
introductions uh today we have ian de
prez who's with us who's our legal
advisor
good morning ian morning sherman uh we
have robert carmichael who's the
governance officer good morning robert
we have gemma walker who's the area
planning manager good morning gemma
and we have bradley heffer daniel
cameron and jamie martin
edwards who are the case officers who
will be presenting uh the various
applications today and good morning to
you
just a reminder that uh ward members
may not vote for applications within
their own ward at mid-south district
council
and therefore board members have the
opportunity to speak if they're on the
committee
they will therefore in effect what we
used to do in the chambers cross the
floor
so they'll be able to speak ask
questions and participate but not
vote in the end the final application
before today is
in my ward therefore at that point i
will step down from chairing the meeting
and hand that over to dave mullet the
vice chair
okay so i'm now going to move on to the
agenda please uh do we have any
apologies for absence
uh and substitution so first of all i
need to ask the governance officer for a
roll call of members
thank you apologies for absence please
oh thank you chess so
uh if i just go to our attendance so
this morning we have apologies from
councillor rachel ebern
and councillor tim passmore and
councillor
uh councillor stringer is substituting
for councillor ebern
and councillor hattingham is substituted
for councillor
passmore and as per our attendance sheet
um everyone is present this morning
chair
um with the exception of council i think
council string might have just got into
modern.gov actually i think that might
dismiss it because you've just gone
green on my screen
so thank you we are all present
i'm afraid you're on mute chair sorry
thank you i'll try not to do that again
uh
can i ask agenda writer number two is to
receive decorations of procuny or
non-pecuniary interest by members
um the only item i'd like to just point
out is i am the county councillor
uh for the debenham uh which is for
debenham which is
one of the applications but that's
obviously just
for interest anyone else wish to declare
anything
no okay lobbying yes we're coming on to
that that's the next item agenda item
number three
declarations of lobbying yes um now i
suspect
we've all been uh lobbied
so can does someone just want to
name the items one person and then we'll
all agree who would like to come in
yeah it's the uh debenham application
and also the hoxson
application chair good everyone anything
beyond that for other members
nope we're all in agreement we've all
had the same letters of lobbying
and correspondence or emails thank you
very much
agenda item number four is declarations
of personal
site visits any declarations of personal
site visits councilor
yeah yes chair i am following the
previous
uh committee um discussion on the hoxon
site which was in the summer uh i did
actually go there because i'd never see
it been there before so i
made a point of going to look at it i i
presume that counts as a site visit
that was back in july or august sometime
thank you thank you for mentioning that
yes
uh we have another hand up councillor
mayor yes as uh
councilman so i also visited that site
after the
initial application
did you hear me thanks very much for
that any other
i'm afraid i'm not getting any hands
coming up on my screen at all
so i i went last time so i don't know
how to say that again but anyway
yeah if you're if you have been thank
you anyone else wish to come in
okay thank you very much agenda item
number four is confirmation the minutes
the meeting that we had on the 11th of
november 2020.
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
nope okay could i have a proposal for
the minutes and a second
please
councillor muller chair thank you thank
you
councillor mayor happy second chair
thank you very much
um governance officer will now conduct
an electronic vote
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the bond.gov
app and go to the plus sign on the
agenda in the top right hand corner
and choose the voting and attendance
button
when you get there if you go if you go
to the attendance and i will start
the vote and it should appear in a light
blue
color
so counts everyone else has voted now so
councillor stringer
um could i please ask for your vote
sorry modern.gov says i've voted
oh have you now oh no you have now sorry
sorry council i did thought i didn't
know that you had got into the voting
part as
we discussed earlier so thank you chair
that is carried by seven votes
zero against with one abstention thank
you very much
okay and agenda item number six is to
res uh sorry the minister meeting have
been confirmed and will be signed at the
next practicable
opportunity thank you uh gender item
number six is to receive notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme do we have any
please
none received here okay thank you agenda
item number seven is schedule of
planning applications
before we begin on the first item i'd
like to draw
note that application dc20585 has been
withdrawn by officers
with my agreement prior to the meeting
to review and report and seek legal
counsel following an appeal decision
okay we will stay uh with the order
that's within our papers so the first
item is dc2002614
land at warren farm the street badwell
ash i now invite the case officer
bradley heffer
to introduce the application to
committee over to you
thank you chair um i just want to make
sure
first that you can see my presentation
if someone could confirm that you can
see yes we can
excellent thank you very much if you
could put it into presentation mode
it'll just make it a bit bigger
yep yep is that okay yeah that's perfect
thank you
marvellous thank you um yes good morning
chair good morning members um you'll
recall this item came to the last
committee meeting on the 11th of
november as a reserve matters
application
for development at badwell
if i quickly go through the slides
leading up to the revisions
this is an aerial view of the the
village itself
and you can see the site mark there and
again
a slightly larger scale map which shows
the built-up area if you can call it
that the village and the
the site we're talking about this is the
constraints map which shows that the
current time the site is outside of the
um
established settlement boundary for the
village although it butts it
um and also there are some
listed buildings which are colored not
in close proximity but fairly close to
the site
the green hatching you can see there is
a special landscape area
and this is the red line plan for the
site
and this is the plan you saw last time
and
various elements of this were not
considered to be acceptable
as identified in my revised report
including
instances such as triple parking
for four bedroom units as shown on 20
and 21
and there are other instances plot 3 for
example
there was concern about the parking
court
which is in the corner here and also the
use of
this space and potential ad hoc parking
taking place and there was queries about
what was happening over at this point
this is the revised plan um if i
quickly go on to a next slide it shows
something in better
or larger detail you'll note that the
parking court has now gone um these
buildings have been reorientated
and i've got parking in front so that
that
sits directly facing that that turning
head
and in terms of a development change
that sits there quite happily obviously
there's parking at the front here but
because it's
it's relatively well tucked behind um
the bulk of the development
the overall visual impact of that we
feel isn't um
you know too bad that's also resulted in
the re-jigging of the
the parking on plots eight nine and ten
um
they've all got individual elements or
sorry individual spaces
within their cartilages which is again
we consider to be an improvement
following on from the revision of that
if i quickly flick back to the previous
thing
um you may recall that in the when the
parking court was being shown in this
location
um visitor spaces were also being shown
these have now been relocated so there's
three
on the open space area in the center and
three on the larger space
nearer the site entrance we feel again
that that's probably a more logical
location for visitor spaces
makes it more spatially um acceptable
for those rather than
being located right in the corner some
of them so that's a convenience
that's that's an improvement as far as
we're concerned
um the elements um
that would address the issue of ad hoc
parking
would be the provision of a kneel knee
rail around
the open space here and again around the
parking space here
so hopefully that would deter any ad-hoc
parking in that location
if i quickly go back to here this strip
of land here
contains part of the anglian water sewer
which crosses the site
as you see dashed in red it's not
intended that this would be formed part
of any cartilage
and you can just about see the gates
that would lock this
sorry would make this inaccessible for
the public
but obviously angling water employees
and the maintenance
team for the site would be able to
get access to that so it wasn't just to
clarify it wasn't ever proposed
to push pedestrians out this way
on to langham road because
this site here sorry this link through
here um
so if i swap back to the bigger one this
link through here
links the site through to the um
the public right-of-way network in the
area
so we feel that that's a an appropriate
way of
of dealing with that link and also of
course if you did push pedestrians out
on a bend
on a de-restricted road believe it or
not um
you know this in terms of the safety
element of it we would be concerned
about encouraging movements
along there anyway um i'll just quickly
run through the um plans again
as i said last time the outline
application includes a
proposed new access into the site um
and as part of the access you'll see
that there's a
new footpath which is being provided
which will link through to existing
provision
further down which is approximately at
that point if you could see my pointer
so there'll be a new footpath going
through there
i'll quickly take you through the
housing types which as i said last time
are very much vernacular approach which
we feel
in this particular location in the
village um is an appropriate
stylistic response and is very similar
to dwellings that sit or newer dwellings
that sit opposite which i'll be able to
show you in a second
and this is some photographs of the site
as is
including the existing access off of the
street um
that's the route down showing the path
where the the
the site where the um the new footpath
will go
um i've taken the liberty of getting an
alternative angle
from google as it says at the top there
just to show you when that is maintained
that the there's sufficient room to get
a path
through there to link through which i
think was raised as a concern
again this is various views across the
site
and you'll see that there's the pond in
the corner which are one of the benefits
of this scheme
we feel would be getting this back into
use as an ecological resource
um so that's something that will be an
enhancement
this is the wider area of open space and
in the
distance you can see newer buildings
which have followed the same sort of
archaeological detailing as is proposed
on some of the units in this current
scheme
and very quickly this is langan road
which is
a lovely rural character which wouldn't
be harmed
because obviously there's a lot of
screening between the road and the
building itself that's a view back
across the village from langham road
um so i'll leave you with the revised
plan i don't propose to say any more
about that at this point
um and hopefully that should be
sufficient for the time being
thank you thank you very much
i have councillor matheson first and
councillor mayor
yeah i have only one question um
section 11 of your report on the
planning obligations
um i was a bit concerned that the
the footway which was almost the last
thing you've just shown us
um isn't isn't listed as one of the
um obligations from the from the outline
um but presumably somewhere along or
rather
we're going to condition that to be paid
for and provided
bradley do you want to come back on that
thank you chair
yes um sorry councillor matheson that is
a condition that was attached to the
outline
planning permission to be listed
under 11.1 then did it yeah apologies
for that there is a list of um
the conditions are attached to the
outline at the end of the
the presentation pack but yes i should
have made that clearer
it is a condition of the planning
permission or the outline
that's all thank you councillor mayor
thank you um plots 18 and 19 appear only
to have one parking space
is that sufficient for a house of that
size
thank you councillor yes 18 and 19
are three bedroom units um i don't know
if you can see my pointer but
um there's a space in front of a garage
on both of those so they've actually
got two spaces for each unit which is in
accordance with
the requirement the garage is one space
and then there's
space in front that that's correct yeah
yeah every other house has two spaces
and a garage
well i think where you've got instances
of three bed units
for example um these ones for example
sorry number four is a three bed unit
that's got a space
and a garage there and
eight nine and ten and some of these
which are
three bed units have got two spaces as
well
okay thank you uh counselor
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
ask about the uh
row end of the road stub where it meets
the link to the
public footpath network um i'm presume
that that is
intended to be a uh sort of reversing
bay
for people who want to who've gone in
forwards into parking spaces
uh it's also access to the footpath is
there going to be
any markings on the road to discourage
parking
in that space um to allow uh maneuvering
of vehicles and pedestrian access to
that footpath link
um i think that the um this area
you're talking about here count so i
think that the uh that you're quite
right that is intended to be a turning
head
and obviously if you're using these
spaces um you would expect to
um actually use that part right up to
there
in order to maneuver your vehicle
as that's a public sorry as that's um
that's that main road going through
there it would be
um kept clear of vehicles um i would
have thought
just for the the practicality of being
able to use the turning head
because there's no need for anyone to
park over here
if they've got their own on spot sorry
on
on-site um parking but something i think
we can we can check with the applicant
councilman so yeah can i just come back
i mean
often there is no need for people to
park uh
in obstructing footpaths but they still
do it so
i think not having a need and having
something to discourage
people are two completely separate items
but
maybe we can come back to that we can
ask the applicant if you want
councilman councillor field
yeah just a couple of points um i
noticed that in
the report in para 2.2 it still talks
about a parking court
um presumably and i think i noticed as i
went through there seemed to a couple of
other references
to the previous application i presume
the drawings override any such
aptly any such comments so it's very
clear is it what we're discussing
um that was one thing and the second
thing perhaps i noticed that in
six five it talks about air source heat
pumps
energy efficient lighting etc and a high
grade of um
if energy efficiency ie slash b whatever
that means
um well so there's two questions one
one about the um ensuring
is the drawings we're following not the
words in the report in
those few areas of difference
but the other one is that those
environmental issues like asl sea pumps
don't appear to be anywhere in the
recommendations in the conditions so are
they
adequately covered to ensure those
things actually get delivered
thank you councilfield bradley
yes thank you chair thank you councillor
um yes
uh the the the report that was produced
last time was would be
produced in full again and has basically
been topped and tailed
uh so references to parking courts
within the previous report
are obviously now superseded by what
you're looking at
on this current drawing there is no
inclusion of a parking court
and again if that's caused confusion
apologies for that
um in terms of the issue with the um
6.5 i think that
we're suggesting that the sustainability
issues that are
raised in that are addressed as part of
a condition
so that we would have further control
over the you know the
actual way that that works in
practicality
where is that condition i didn't notice
it didn't
um i think it's possibly summarized at
the end of the report
page 48 detail
48. no can i say the recommendations are
on page 27
not 48. 27.
brad there is a um submission of a
scheme for water energy and resource
efficiency measures but to say during
construction should that be during
construction
and um
[Music]
ongoing rather than just simply
construction yeah well i think that
in the case of this one um there was the
outline planning permission which was
granted
which has that condition on it but that
missed out
the outline condition missed out the
construction phase
so to tighten that up we've imposed a
sustainability condition on the the you
know on the reserve matters approval as
well
okay so it is covered yep yeah yeah okay
thank you okay uh
yeah councilman was just going to going
to raise that that the question about
that condition
um if we got to the point of of um
nearly approving it actually but i love
at that point john i'm hoping that
the the full detail on page 48 will
apply
um and the word during is is a bit
bit confusing really um it's a scheme
for the lifetime of the um of the
development really isn't it
so as long as we all clear about what
that condition will look like in detail
when it's issued
sorry sorry john i think you just got to
be clear page 48
yeah has nothing is so so the
recommendations before us so only those
on page 27.
before this committee today yeah chair
not normally the
the the conditions are are summarized in
those bullet points
and and in practice when the permissions
issued
one gets a very very much more detailed
explanation and page 48 seems to be and
similarly
no doubt there are other pages that
would be the detail of other bullet
points so
i'm just making sure that um we are
getting the full
um the full recommendation from the um
consultee
thank you sorry jeff i could just add
for
uh councillor matheson's um
information in the um agenda on page 71
there's the condition number 15 which
deals specifically with
water energy and resource efficiency
measures during the operational invasive
development
so there is that imposed headline yeah
and then the the one that i've um
summarized in the papers today in
relation to this report
relates purely to the constructional
phase i see that's very helpful thank
you
thanks very much right i don't have any
other hands up on my system anyone else
have any questions
nope okay so we'll move on um so as we
don't have a representative of the
parish council we don't have an objector
or a supporter
i'll now ask the agent graham bloomfield
to speak mr bloomfield you have up to
three minutes
if you could turn your camera on please
can you see me i can't but can
others still got this site layout here
yeah i think we need to take the site
layout down first
please bradley
there we go
so if you turn your camera on
yeah my camera is on i can see myself
oh there you go you've just come through
okay welcome uh and you have three
minutes and um
uh mr carmichael will be has the timer
going over to you
okay thank you chair and uh members of
the planning committee uh my name is
graham bloomfield i'm
london planning partner william h brown
acting as agent for this application
um i'd like to say we're delighted to be
able to return back to planning
committee within one month of the
previous deferral
and i'd like to thank officers at mid
suffolk uh council for all their hard
work and allowing us to do so
and also the architects and consultant
team from chatsworth homes
we consider the scheme in front of you
today as summarized in the offices
report
addresses the the points um from the
november committee meeting that saw the
application deferred
i think consistent with the progress of
the application as a whole
uh this demonstrates my clients
willingness to work collaboratively with
the council and its officers
and respond positively to comments that
have been made
the current proposals retain the same
high quality
landscape led scheme as negotiated with
offices that was largely
considered positively by members last
time around however we accept the need
to address
the points that were raised the first of
these is the removal of the rear parking
court
which allowed for a redesign of the
southwestern corner of the site
um providing more immediately accessible
parking spaces for those units and a
further benefit of larger gardens for
those affordable units as well
this has allowed the removal of all
instances of tandem parking through
further tweaks to the scheme
um and the visitor parking is now more
accessible
and i think a particular benefit is it's
now spread more evenly
throughout the site again making it more
accessible to all
we provided further clarity on the
nature of that parking
um confirming that the open space is
informal recreation
mainly grass and planting and
demonstrated the measures that will
prevent
vehicles parking on those spaces most
notably
the 0.6 meter high knee rail fencing
around the parking spaces themselves
finally we've provided clarity on the
strip of land between units 16 and 17
as a service strip for angling water
that will be locked
and accessed only by the management
company and angling water themselves
um we did consider with officers the
potential for footpath link that was
discussed at the previous committee
meeting
but for the reasons outlined by by
bradley um we didn't think that was
um there was limited additional benefit
in terms of the uh the sort of desire
lines from that and outweighed by a
number of concerns
with langham road the national speed
limit lack of footpaths
popping out on a bend and there's also a
slight drop in levels down to to that
road as well
um plus the removal of a section of
hedge to create it
um so therefore that that was considered
but uh we didn't move forward with that
but otherwise have looked to address
um you know and work with officers to
address all previous comments
um we therefore politely request that
members endorse
the officer's recommendation and i'm
happy to take any further questions
thank you very much for that and thank
you um could you just answer sarah
mansell's point uh councillor mansell's
point around um
how you prevent people walking over
obviously obviously the cars apart
access to the footpath and how you're
gonna stop people parking in that
turning area because it could become
tempting
i mean i think that the point is that
that that turning head is obviously
is designed almost specifically to
access
um units 11 and 12 and 10. so there is a
requirement for that to be
kept clear at all times so as part of
the overall management of the scheme
and how we demark that that surface um
clearly we would want to keep that clear
which then has the you know so it's for
the benefit of those
the occupants of those units they need
access at all times those spaces but
that in turn then frees up
you know or stop there being vehicles at
that end that will stop people getting
through to the the public right away
link
so so it's yeah we'd absolutely want to
to attain that as open
okay uh we've got some hands that have
come up so first of all councillor
muller
uh thank you chair uh mr bloomfield just
one question
can you confirm whether or not there are
plans to put electrical vehicle charging
points in the properties
on this development please i think we
have a requirement
under the there's a condition on on sort
of environmental performance that
i think picking up discussion it
actually is covered more by the the
outlying consent than than the current
consent but i think
certainly it's something that we are
yeah we're actively looking at
as a requirement thank you very much
councillor matheson thank you chair
um yeah i'm pleased to see the the air
source heat pumps
and um i did wonder have you considered
um i can't see them on the plans um
including
um photovoltaic panels to produce
the electricity for the um heat pumps
and indeed the
electric cars which previous uh
questions
looking for i think the scheme as we've
presented at the moment is more focused
on the the air source heat pumps that
meets the
would meet the policy requirements for
for renewables and for
you know reusing energy on site um
i suppose the challenge for
photovoltaics is they do have more of
maybe an external
appearance so at the moment that's not
what we've proposed
we are looking at alternative methods
that meet policy
um but again that's something that would
be the detail would be
dealt with um through that condition on
the the outline scheme
could you could you perhaps consider
offering
offering pvs as an option um
at the point of sale because obviously
it's a lot cheaper to put them on
um during the build than it is to have
people come back with scaffolding and
what not afterwards
when people decide that they want to um
reduce their electricity bills
yeah i mean i have to be very candid
that that i won't be um
you know i'm the planning agent rather
than the the house builder so
can't make those promises to you but i'm
happy to feed that back to my class
pass that thought on thank you
very much councilman uh
thank you chair i i just back back to
the the
road surface uh and please forgive me if
it's in the papers and i haven't read it
uh and and my memory might be wrong but
i seem to remember from the last
committee that this road
was not was going to remain a private
road and not be adopted
um what is the road surface is it going
to be the same all the way through
or is it going to be mixed surface or or
what
i just wonder whether um changing the
surface might make people realize it's
not a road and it's a
it's it's a turning head or something
i mean i think that the general ethos of
the scheme is to have a
shared surface running through through
the center of the site so
the main spine road for once a better
word will be a shared surface
um to encourage you know that it's not
dominated by cars and indeed you know
cars will use it as briefly as possible
to access
parking spaces and get off that bit of
highway
um so again there is a a landscaping
scheme a hard landscaping scheme that is
conditioned it's something if it is a
particular concern we could work
with that and look at the materials and
how we
it's that sort of trying to recognize
that that change isn't it um
and the perception of people that
utilizing a material that suggests this
is
you're entering more a sort of footpath
and you know entering the public right
away
i'm happy to look at sort of options for
that um but but you know that
it would have been keeping the general
ethos that this is not a
a car dominated you know black tarmac um
that it's for it's for all it's for
walkers cyclists etc
thank you uh casa matson i think is that
an old hand
councillor field over to you
yes just to continue the environmental
bit
i think the thing that we're trying to
ensure is that paragraph
6.5 of the report
is implemented and that includes
slt pumps nug efficient
internal and external lighting which is
sort of obvious
provision of water saving measures
electric vehicle
charging points for each dwelling except
submitted details summarized as follows
and i won't carry on reading because you
can all read at least as well as i can
but i'm you know what i'm seeking to
ensure
is that somewhere in the conditions
those
offers which are part of the
documentation we're reading
are going to come to fruition
thank you
bradley do you want to comment on that i
mean because the counselor makes a good
point i mean that's in our papers under
6.5 and
do we take it all those are in the
conditions categorically
i think to avoid any um doubt chair
the wording that's been identified in
the report
could be incorporated within the
condition
um to avoid any doubt whatsoever the
other thing i should say
i think it's been raised by a couple of
members with regard to
electric charging points again
on page 71 in the outline planning
permission
they're specifically conditioned 13 they
did raise that
so we are looking to get electric
charging points across the site
across the development anyway thank you
could i just point out mr bloomfield did
seem to have some doubts on that so
it's up to the committee if we want to
condition it to cancer field
if we go down that route then um that
would avoid
any doubt thank you
any other questions for the agent
no okay thank you very much thank you
very much for joining us mr bloomfield
okay next we now move to the ward member
councillor richard mayer
councillor mayor over to you thank you
chair um
i have no comments to make really the
um parish council working for the path
the path has been provisioned and they
had concerns over the central area
and that has been protected so i have no
other
no other comments to make
okay uh any questions for the ward
member
no okay uh so members
uh we obviously we've had the
application before us before it's now
come back to us
in a different format uh four weeks
later it's really up to us to debate
uh discuss um and to
see which direction we go who would like
to
start off we do it by hands rather than
calling everyone out i'm
a counselor stringer and then councillor
manson
uh thank you chair uh i think this is uh
sometimes when we uh uh pontificate on
these committees
we wonder if we're actually doing any
good uh i actually think this is a
classic case
of a committee adding considerable value
to a development
so frankly i mean it's people didn't get
in the first place
having said that we we are there as a
backstop we are there as a double check
and i feel in this this role uh we've
done our job the parish council's uh
now pretty much on board with this and i
think frankly
uh we've got as probably as good a
scheme as we were likely to get here
so i will personally be voting in favor
of this uh
and and would not mind moving approval
if that's appropriate thank you chair
yeah happy to take that thank you
councillor stringer councillor mansell
thank you chair um uh i i too actually
think that this is a much improved
scheme
over the last time we saw this a month
ago um
and i think it's uh it's very pleasing
to see that the developers have been
working with our
officers to uh come up with this plan i
think the
removal of the rim parking court is is a
it makes it a much better
layout um and if um council stringer
uh actually made a proposal there i
wasn't sure if he was or not
i'm happy to second um provided we do
get those words in about the sustainable
energy and water usage yes i did take
cancer strongest as a proposal so in
which case i'll second
it thank you councillor matheson
thank you yes um yeah i i'm
just i'm certainly i entirely agree that
we would
well justified in in saying this isn't
quite quite good enough
i mean i think it's a pity that the um
the comments of the landscaping that
would work a lot better with one less
um one less dwelling was not
not accepted but um i think that beyond
that
it's it's all um it's all good stuff i i
am just slightly um going to press again
the point that we
um that we do get into the conditions
between the outline
that we've already got and and this one
all the recommendations that the
sustainability officer has got on page
48 and 49
um i think we've covered most of the
points that are
on there so it's just a question of
getting the details
written down thank you thank you very
much councillor field
yeah i hate to say the same thing and be
monotonous but i i think um
you know this seemed to be a good
development
and uh if it does make the uh
the sustainability measures it's quite
forward-looking
uh and obviously to the in meets favor
with the parish council
and seems a a decent layout now that
we've managed to
get some improvement to the parking so i
totally support
the application providing it has as
has been said several times the
condition concerning um
sustainability thank you thanks very
much council food counselor mueller
thank you chair yes i too totally
support this application and we'll be
voting in favor of it
and again i would like to thank the
developer and the officers for coming up
with this revised plan
so quickly thank you thank you uh thank
you
i don't have any other hands up and and
i just agree with everything said it is
really good that something comes to
committee
we say could you go away and we want to
defer it for the following reasons
and see it come back so i echo the
points that have already been made
and thank please do thank uh pass on our
thanks to
um the applicant uh if the agent could
pass that on because
this is a this is a very positive story
which is good to have
okay so it has been proposed by
councillor stringer
and seconded by councillor
mansell as per the recommendations on
our paper
on page 27 with the addition
of bullet point 6.5 on page 21
uh being part of those recommendations
and conditions so there's absolute
clarity
everything mentioned on 6.5 on page 21
is to be included in the recommendation
is that
are you happy with that counselor
stringer and counselor mansell
very happy chair yes okay
so uh now that's uh i now ask the chief
planning officer
just to confirm that they're happy with
that before we go to the vote
and if so we will then ask the
governance officer to conduct an
electronic vote
yeah thank you that's just what i was
gonna say so it's the recommendation for
approval on page 27 with the additional
wording of paragraph 6.5
in the report so yep that's that would
be the recommendation that we're looking
at
thank you thank you very much uh so over
to the governance officer please
thank you chair so i think i've managed
to get that all in
quickly enough on to the vote so i would
hopefully
it should now also appear when i start
it
on now so the vote should now be open so
if members could go to
the agenda and modern.gov and the plus
sign
and go to attendance and voting and
please go
um and choose your vote
right thank you chair that is carried
unanimously
lovely thank you very much now members
um
i'm going to have to make a change um
originally
because the agenda was longer
uh i assured councillor guthrie who had
an appoint urgent appointment this
morning
that um that she would her item would
not happen to at least after 10
30 and rather than just sitting and
waiting i think what we'll do is we'll
go straight to the
third application the hoxton application
uh
just to be fair because i'm afraid i'd
at that point obviously
uh oh you're here good okay so we can
continue
and is the parish council here as well
from debenham please can we confirm
robert
uh the parish council have chosen not to
speak um they've got
a representation in the table papers
chair fine
okay so that's fine so we can continue
as planned okay well that's
thanks uh councillor guthrie for getting
here and sorry about
the obviously we had to withdraw that
one application so we'll move on to item
agenda
item number 7c in the paper uh dc
20 02129
so thank you chair chad um
okay same um process as bradley i'll
bring up my presentation and if someone
can confirm that
they can view it as well that would be
good um let's get to the start and full
screen it for you
is everybody able to see the
presentation
we are thank you thank you chair um
yes so we have the application before us
dc twenty
zero two one two nine um for land
southeast of low road in debenham
it is a full application and it is for
the erection of 18
new dwellings including six affordable
dinings
with construction and access from low
roads
if we come in we have the um site
location hashed in
pink and outlined in orange we have the
gardeners road
estate to the north west we have
the cherry tree farmhouse and buildings
to the northeast
then to the rest of the site and you'll
see this as we pull out within the
aerials
we have a number of large agricultural
field patterns
surrounding the site
and there we go we can see the rest of
debenham up to the north
of the application site there as well
if we come slightly further out
the application site is almost at the um
r or y of cherry tree green underneath
debenham there in the center of your
screen
um we're not too far from stoner masspel
we're roughly equidistant between stone
market and framlingham
and we have the relationship with the
other villages
visible there as well um
i want to come now to the debenham
neighborhood plan because while
the application site is outside the
second boundary of debenham
although not for the emerging joint
local plan um
the allocation in this case comes from
the dependent neighborhood plan so this
is the
um site allocation plan that accompanies
the demod plan
and the relevant parcel we're looking at
is dev4 i don't know if you can see my
pointer here it's this parcel of land
here and we have this passage of land
also in green deb
three which is another housing
allocation within
neighbourhood plan and as you'll see
from the information provided to you in
the report the two
go together um i've also just for
clarity um
included the uh
text from the development network plan
with regards to the allocation for dev
three and depth four
um the allocation for dev4 is repeated
in your report members
um but i wanted this to be here for
clarity so
if we start with dev three there's four
hectares of agricultural land
um to deliver between 640
new homes with access to this site to be
taken
from ipswich road we then have
deb for one hectare of agricultural land
for delivery of 15 to 35
new homes um issues
raised within the neighborhood plan with
regards to debt four
include the flood risk at the site
frontage which we'll come to in a moment
with the constraints plan
um archaeology and um
that access should be restricted to low
road with only pedestrians and cyclists
being able to make access there
uh this is a site location plan
and then if we come to this constraints
map um
we have three grade two listed buildings
um
in the vicinity the most important of
which is um
cherry tree farmhouse for this site
um but in particular members should be
aware of the sort of fuzzy black lines
that run across the site frontage
um this is
a part of uh flood zone two and three
across the site frontage there
um if we go quickly into slight layout
we have a good degree of um
planting buffer around the access to the
site frontage onto low road
and we then have the proposed
development of the site coming forward
in three phases with phase
one um to cover the frontage of the site
and road layout
we then have phase two to cover delivery
of affordable housing
and a number of open market units and
then we have delivery of
phase three which is the remainder of
the site for the open market
um within that we have um
spilled the building layout for you
members um
the purple and the blue units relate to
the affordable housing
um they're delivered as three two bed
houses and three one bed bungalows
we then have the remainder of the site
set out
at the back of the site we have these
red and teal
units these are bungalows and then
towards the site frontage we have two
story units
we then go through the various
house types through the plot starting
with the affordable housing and running
through
the remainder of the plots now
within the report we're clear that
the access to low roads is not as it
would be
required um under the site allocation
now in coming to this there are two main
areas why this has been pursued at this
time
[Music]
the first is that there is a restrictive
covenant on the land
subject the land to the south of the
site
laid out in the reports for you this
employ
parts and overage clause should um
residential development come forward on
that site by 2025
um and would effectively see a
percentage of the uplifting land value
go
back to the original landowner um on
this basis it's considered unlikely that
this site would come forward
um in advance of 2025
and given the the likely times in which
um the site would be built out
it's likely that that might prejudice
the delivery of this site and indeed if
deb3 was not to come forward at all
it's considered that this site would be
completely undeliverable without an
access onto low road
now in consulting with the highways
authority they're content with
the access onto the road for 18 dwelling
weeks
um it's likely that we're
here to see deb three come forward
um the highway authority would likely
want to see that closed up
and i think it's within our power
counsellors to um
effect a solution that might see
if deb3 comes forward a solution that
might see that access stopped up so for
emergency access only
and for pedestrians and cyclists to make
use of that access
um there's just two further points to
note members
um and our runners back
into the layout which might be most
useful for your discussions
um but the two points to note are that
in the last section of the report where
those references made to the securing of
affordable housing
um under the provisions of a section
106. it's been brought to my attention
by the agent
that there is um movement at
national government level to update the
mppf and effectively that update would
replace the provision for starter homes
with something similar
provision for first homes and at present
it appears as though the provision for
first homes
would be accompanied by a requirement a
certain percentage of affordable
units on sites be provided as first
homes
so therefore that would prevent a
challenge to the council's adopted
policy of
70 of affordable units being provided as
affordable rented units and 30
being afforded offered as shared
ownership
um several councils in the area have
already updated their emergent policies
or policies within
um adopted plans to make um light of
this but it's
thought that the percentage of first
homes delivered would be between
probably about 20
and 25 and that would be required by
government so
the only thing to note with that members
is that we might not be able to achieve
the 70 30 split that we normally do
but that would be due to changes in
national planning policy that would have
to be reflected in the section 106.
the other point to note is within your
table papers we have a further
representation from
um then parish council
they know particularly that they would
want to see pedestrian cycle access
maintained through to
the neighboring site within the
submitted landscaping plan we have
pedestrian and cycle access provided
through this area of open space
so would be provided in that instance
um and would be secured by conditions
and and
legal obligations within section 106 um
the other thing to note
is that the development will bring
forward an element of sill
um part of which would be transferred to
the parish council and could be utilized
with
um utilized by them to further their own
um
[Music]
further their home projects with regards
to walking and cycling improvements can
then debit them as a whole
i'll leave that there members
okay okay thank you thank you so
questions
um thank you um so daniel have you got
any uh pictures photos of um low road
like what the from the from the access
route from the access you know yes i do
thank you for that
that reminds me um so just before we get
to this point
members i need to apologize because i
had more photos but in
updating the um powerpoint presentation
a number of them within the site appear
to be corrupted so i'm going to aren't
going to be visible for you
but this is the view towards debenham a
long low road from the site access
and this is the view going the other way
at this point low road is probably at
its widest point and there is a scheme
within
the application to further widen it
although not to a
significant degree but we do have um
footpath running up the side on the
opposite side of the road from the site
um leading in both directions although i
would note that this
ends um slightly further up around the
corner
and then obviously as we move
round the site low road titans um
and parking on street becomes more of an
issue
in terms of traffic movement so back and
forth along the road
thank you have you also got a sort of a
shot of debenham so we can just see how
ipswich road and this low road sort of
fit in with the rest of the village
yes
you sort of showed something initially
but it wasn't particularly clear
so we have this the location plan
showing the immediate um
area but i think probably um
this might be better or we could zoom in
slightly
so you've got uh point out where the the
co-op is and the main the main
facilities and the leisure center
yeah so we've got we've got the leisure
center up here through the gardner's
road estate
and then the carp is located um
up the main road within debenham
slightly further it's not within the
shot but it's where
roughly where my mouse is pointing but
i'm sure i can be um
move to a more um correct location by
by members who might be more familiar
with the area
that is correct yeah yeah okay cool
thank you
so the the uh cherry tree pub as it was
is on the court is can you just point
where that out is yeah so that's not
that's another lettering surgery right
so that's that's on this corner here i
think
okay thank you uh councillor matheson
yeah i didn't find the um the the
flooding constraints
um map very um illuminating or clear
unfortunately
um it's quite what was what was
happening there
with all these fuzzy lines and so on
especially at that scale
um whether you can getting closer to
that or what what are you
saying if we just show all the spaces
between the two black
let's get daniel just to talk us through
through it again
yeah of course thank you so present we
have a ditch that runs along the site
frontage
um with low roads um
and and that's why we have the the black
line so the black lines just show
um the extent of the area but
effectively
the frontage of the site is under parts
um
flood zone two and flood zone three um
so within that if we come to
the site phasing layout um
we have the extent of the flood zone
mapped out
with this green line so none of the
development is within the flood zone and
within the flood zone
what is proposed is um quite extensive
landscaping
and flood attenuation
in order to lessen that impact
in terms of consultations with the flood
and water management team
they're content that um what's shown and
what would be
built out would be sufficient um to
allow residential development on the
site
so so what is it so the the the flood
map is showing us a ditch
each side of low road is it
no so the the ditch runs and it's
roughly the line
that the um i've got that one the blue
line here so there's a ditch runs along
here
another black squiggly line the other
side of the road that that shows the
extent of potential flooding
that's the edges that's it the edges
okay well i think
my key question really then is um
what's the provision for pedestrian um
egress from the development in the event
of flooding
which which is anticipated to happen
from time to time
no exactly so within within the scheme
of conditions members we've included
um conditions such that our emergency
planners are
uh um able to give comment
effective effectively what tends to
happen is that all the dwellings are
signed up to flood alerts
um and then depending on whether there
is a dry
exit from the site or not um
the the the flood risk evacuation plan
either kicks in or doesn't kick in so if
if there is no dry exit
um then
the advice is normally to stay stay in
place and
wait for waters to recede
and in such situations you know make
sure that you have
the appropriate contact numbers for
services you might need to access
emergency services
um the power network gas network
know where the appropriate shut offs are
i thought when we were dealing with the
one up the road from here
that perhaps the chair actually referred
to earlier was it that one
where we we were um we were insisting
that would there would be a
a one in a hundred pedestrian uh
access to get out um
provided i seem to recall
it's the one i'm thinking of and i'm
pretty sure it is actually
so this is this is dependent on the plan
rather than
having a 1 in 100 dry
access then well you would have you
would have
access through to the land behind the
site
and the access as it's designed the
majority of it is above
um
the problem is is that low road as it
stands is underneath
that level yes i understand it
okay thank you councillor field
sorry i councillor guthrie i noticed
your hands gone up as well i don't know
the order because
i only have the attendees come up so
i'll ask uh after council announcer i'll
bring in councillor guthrie
okay uh my first points really were
about
flooding as well so the real question is
have we met the requirements on page 179
there's a paragraph l edited
recommendations and that's from the
flood
and water management people so have we
really met that
um i assume things like the the fact
is the culver big enough to take the
flow of water without backing up further
is has
been answered but i'd like some
confirmation
because it talks here about safe escape
routes
and accesses for emergency vehicles
just like some assurance that we really
have satisfied that not just
skated over it um
there's a question further on on page
105 in the debenham
uh local plan the um
neighbourhood plan that talks about any
planning application must be supported
by a program of archaeological
evaluation and i think later on in the
report that seems to get
dismissed i would just be like to be
sure that um
that's been dismissed with good thought
not just ignored
um and the final point i would make
is um
didn't see anything like um heat pumps
and
non-fossil fuel requirements in this
area
environmental requirements have we
considered those
or not
yes thank you councillor so in terms of
um
the ditch at present there's no culvert
over at present but would be if the
access were implemented
now that meets the design requirements
for the lead flood and water authority
so
there's not an issue there and in terms
of the emergency accesses we have the
conditions and the um
other points i already went through with
councillor matheson
in terms of archaeology um
the site has been submitted for
consultation with um suffolk's
archaeological
service um they know that they
have no record of um
archaeological fines in the area and
don't consider it necessary
that an archaeological survey is carried
out on the site so we haven't pulled
forward conditions to that end
on the basis of that and with regards to
the final point about
sustainability if councillors would be
supportive then we can certainly add a
condition in
such that prior to commencement we have
a scheme of sustainability
and sustainability measures renewable
technologies
um all those sorts of things submitted
um
by the developer
thank you i'd certainly like to see that
thank you uh councillor
thank you chair um uh following on from
uh the previous
question about sustainability um
and this is a full planning application
uh my first question
is to do with car parking um there
appear to be
two um terraces on the eastern
side or sorry on the on the what
my plan is i don't know which way which
way north is on my plan
but on the end closest to the centre of
debenham
uh there appear to be some terraces um
the one of them looks like it does have
parking spaces
outside the properties the other one
doesn't um is there going to be any
scope for
adding um ev charging uh
for those terraced houses and actually
while you've got slide 10
on the on the thing hpd slide 10 isn't
included in our pack
because that i think is a much clearer
diagram so my first question is about
parking and
whether there's scope for electric
vehicles charging points for all the
properties
um when you showed us the picture of low
road
there's quite extensive hedging on that
side and some trees
um can we say how much of that hedging
will need to be removed and will any of
the large trees need to be removed
thank you so in terms of parking spaces
on site
um yeah we have
parking at the side here for some of the
three here and then parking
the other side and then we have this bay
of parking
for the affordable bungalows at this
side
um with regards to ev charging points um
the gdpo is quite um
flexible now in terms of being able to
provide those
without the need for planning permission
so there's absolutely no problem with
those being added at a later date i
think what normally
facilitates that in a manner um
[Music]
that that just makes it far far easier
is the inclusion of ducting
to those um uh
parking areas so that in terms of
installation you go down to the ducting
and then run your cables through the
existing ducting
rather than having to to lay fresh cable
inducting yourself
so i have absolutely no problem with
a a condition that would require the
provision of ducting
um throughout the site for for ev
charging points
um with regards to tree and hedging yeah
we're putting in an access
and and some of the the trees and hedges
to the site access are going to have to
be removed to facilitate that and to
facilitate
visibility displays um for the most part
that's been kept to a minimum
um such that we try and retain as much
um
of of the the verdant character the
frontage of the site as possible
um where that's not possible and where
we've removed things
within the rest of that open space to
the frontage
um we've tried to replacement plants as
far as possible
in order to offset that loss
thank you can i just come back with
another question that i forgot in my
first round
please do um the the um
requirement for the pedestrian and cycle
connectivity to
um deb three whenever it materializes
um is that you know do we have absolute
assurance
that that will not become a ransom strip
and that will be provided in due course
when deb3 comes forward i mean
i don't know how we can secure it i mean
is that possible to
have absolute confidence that that will
happen
well i think i think the way to so in
terms of
um the landscape layout we have that we
have that provided
um we have that provided here so in
terms of bringing that forward we'll be
able to control that through condition
and secure osx
if there are at all any concerns about
bringing that forward
in order to make connection through to
the site
um to the south then i think potentially
members might want to give some
considerations as to whether they want
to
see that land transferred to them um
in order that when the next site comes
forward
there isn't an issue um with providing
that connection up
now there are obviously caveats to that
in that it
one relies on the next site coming
forward
um for development and two it relies on
um the developer being willing to
to work with us to provide that
connection i then think the third point
is that if we were going to provide a
connection through
um through this site um
with regards to um the development
neighborhood plan we want to be sure
that there is something
in place to allow the stopping up of
this access onto low road
because i think probably at the moment
the highway authority have assessed the
impact of 18 dwellings
coming forward onto this onto this site
if we go
back to um the allocation
for depth through i think we're talking
between 60 and
140 new units and i think if we were to
look at
you know the potential impact of between
80 and 150 units on on low road
then that might be very different so i
think probably the third the third point
would be um can we agree with the
highway authority to
you know affect the stopping up of the
access to low road for everything
apart from emergency vehicles
can i come in there as well councillor
um it's almost a bit of a reverse
um position in that these houses will
have had their permission they'll be up
and running
and it would be potentially the
committee's um
option to refuse planning permission on
the southern side
if the access through to this site isn't
included because it is a neighborhood
plan policy
um so as far as this application we are
protecting that option it will still
remain available and open
and as daniel said it would then be
subject to
agreement with highways as to how we um
blocked up or prevented at least a car
access
through this site onto low road
thanks bringing council guthrie then
i've got some follow-up questions on on
this point
councillor guthrie uh
thank thank you chair um my
my first question was um actually
brought well lots of questions were
brought up
um but was where are all the photographs
on this um
i and my questions are where are the
photographs there's only two
it's not really very appropriate for the
site and the difficulties
this site has but that's a comment but
my question was where were where were
all the
uh photographs and i'll come on to that
in my report
um and secondly um daniel mentioned
about um the changes in the current
requirements under the section 106
but are they law at the moment for the
uh allocation of houses how can that be
for this type of thing and yet we can't
use our own jlp or whatever
because it's only still in the stages
could i have an explanation on the
housing allocations and the affordables
please thank you chair
um council guys i don't know if you
heard but the start uh daniel said that
he's had a corruption on his files this
morning so only two photos were showing
even though he had many more
um yeah no i didn't i did hear that but
thank you no no i apologize for that and
obviously
you know it is it is um difficult for
committee to
be fully appraised of a site when
something like that happens
um slightly unavoidable and i can only i
can only offer apologies
and and try and make sure that um yeah
save them in
save them in two places and avoid the um
the corruption of them um
later i mean with regards to the point
on i
i assume we're talking about the um
changes to affordable housing
um normally when the government makes
changes
to the mppf they're just published as an
update
um and there's no sort of um
process to go through in terms of um
checking or verifying them it's just
offered out as an update
and and that is then from that point
becomes part of the mppf
the only reason i bring it up for
members to be aware of
is that um
that is an expected publication
um and in terms of um
the process in completing and signing a
section 106
um there is a little bit of a delay so
it is is just in terms of
if um if that application updates the
mppf were to come out
and be published and be be part of what
we need to look at in terms of preparing
the section 106
we might need to just
[Music]
look at and temper expectations in terms
of
what we're legally allowed to secure for
the affordable housing
and it was just it was just offered for
information really because
at present time i don't have a time
frame for that although
since the publication of the um white
paper on planning
um this appears to be the the point that
the government wants to um
you know push first through the um the
doorway into
into the mppf as it were i think i think
a lot of other points they want to take
further time on and and ponder but this
seemed to be something that they were
keen to um
progress and bring forward
did you want to come back counselor
guthrie
no he's made it clear to the committee
members who'll be making the decision on
that thank you chair
thanks and can i just ask some questions
then um
please um with the case office so
firstly
um so the access through to low road
we're we're talking about introducing a
way to get that blocked up
subject to the other access being coming
through
but how how do you make sure that
someone who's
who's moving into one of these houses is
fully aware of that will that come up in
a search because
they might be in for a shock to suddenly
discovered their access that
they think is the access to the site is
suddenly no longer available so
how does that get in actual process and
reality so someone is moving in not
under false pretenses
secondly um how could one of the one of
the questions has been around
legal obligation to allow and provide
pedestrian cycle access across the site
so that you can come in from effectively
what will in the long term be
three ways but obviously you've talked
about the one at the
uh the the bottom end of our picture now
how can that be secured and will it be
secured so that
it actually is provided for and does
stay as being
a legal obligation to have that access
how does that work can you just explain
those two yeah so i i think there are
so if we go to the um point of the
access and we'll come on to the footways
and cycleways
um with regard to the access um
yeah we we could we could have something
easily on our
documents in terms of an informative
that would give direction to that
um we obviously have the provisions
within the neighborhood plan
um but i i take the point i is
it is difficult to make sure that
everyone purchasing a unit on that site
would be aware
of of the potential for the restriction
of the access
and and the access will be a far longer
and tortuous route to the site when
that's blocked off
for some of the residents that's yeah
that would that would be that would be
the other point
um i mean that is that is how the the
site was envisaged to work within the
debenham neighborhood plan
um that this would effectively be an
addition to
the site to the south um but i think
probably at the time there was no
notion that there was a restricted
covenant on that on that site and that
actually
the sites would be coming around almost
in reverse order to how they envisaged
it when they were drawing up the
neighborhood plan
so sorry can i just follow up so is
there any way that that can be
overturned so if we if permission is
granted on that basis of that being
closed up is there any way that can be
overturned
or is that absolutely set in stone i
think i think we would need to
i think i think members would want to
retain some flexibility for the council
um just in order to secure you know if
we don't have
if the site to the south doesn't come
forward we'd need to retain the access
to low road we'd want to retain a
highways access there
and at most we would only be dealing
with 18 units coming out onto low road
which the highway authority have
assessed and is content with i think
if we were to see deb three come forward
and we were able to connect this site up
with ipswich road then we need to bring
forward the scheme to close up
um the access onto the road because what
would what would effectively happen
is that you would have um yeah between
80 and 150 units or potentially being
able to
use that that low road access i mean
and i think probably what we would want
to do in that situation
is go forward with a scheme to to block
off that road but i think
that would all be within if members were
content to take the the area open space
um as a transfer to the council
we could then own that area of land so
we would then be in control of
of what happened to it in the provision
of a of a link through to that site
and it's only with um agreeing that with
us
which would be within members gifts and
then the closing up of that which we
would then be in control of the timing
of so effectively we would say
well we won't close this off until the
link through is provided but once a link
through is provided we will have a
a period whereby within you know say
three months or six months depending on
um
the time scales that the highway
authority can work to that that is then
closed off to all the emergency vehicles
okay one other question because i've got
other people so is it common for
mid-suffolk to want to take over land i
thought we were trying to do the
opposite and reduce liability
no yes so i think that's um that is that
is the case yeah in terms of
um areas of open space we definitely
want to see those retained
by management companies or by by the
developer for
for maintenance but i think probably in
in this instance
um and this this is something the
members will need to judge for
themselves
there is potentially a benefit in
um taking the land or or having option
um i think on the land secured within
a section 106 just to be able to
then facilitate that access through to
the site to the south
if that comes forward at a later date
i think that's something for members to
be aware of but i think
as as you say councillor that you know
there is a
program within the council at the moment
to not be taking on
um new sections of land and to
um you know see those retained by by the
developer and and maintained at their
expense rather than ours
yeah can i come in there i'd probably
suggest that might be something we
bottom out through the section 106
process
this strikes me as various options as to
how we could have that come forward
as dan said an option on the land a
process for calling various requirements
i'm sure in could provide us some more
information if members need that
but essentially i think we're saying we
can and will secure an access through
this site to is it deb
iii i think and we can close off
the access to low road that would be in
the um control of the highways authority
so that would all be within uh
sufficient control
and that we could finalize those details
in the section 106 if members are happy
with that
and equally as i mentioned earlier
potentially if the
um southern side was to come forward
without this
would that be possibly a reason for
refusal at that time that could be
something that's given due consideration
under that given the neighborhood plan
policy so i think
from my point of view we're securing as
much as we possibly can
whilst allowing the houses to come
forward um
and it's whether that's sufficient
balance for members um to do so
thank you councilman over to you thank
you yes
um officers and indeed the chairs have
extensively gone
back and forth across the main question
that i wanted to
ask really so all i'm left with on those
points really is that
um that we would we would keep
a pedestrian and cycle access into low
road
but we will take take to ourselves
um a certainty that we can we can close
it to vehicle traffic i think it's where
we're
we're getting to on that which which is
which is what i think is necessary
and i think the the debate now john it's
a solution what's
yeah fair point the other question is
can we
can we take the all of page 219
sustainability condition as what we will
be getting
and adding to the um to the recommended
conditions
uh well daniel page 219 can you just
comment on that please
yeah of course just um catching up with
members in terms of where they are in
the report
um let's have a look
yes we can see that implemented i don't
think there's a there's an issue with
that members
thank you very much if we're looking if
we're looking at the conditions for a
moment the other one i just asked about
biodiversity i think we do that i think
you bring those in
subject to whatever proposals made yeah
fine thank you
um unless you've got any questions on
particular points within it otherwise we
can just bring it in when we get to that
if we get to that stage
if you're happy with that okay um
right well so now move on we don't have
a representative from the parish council
we don't have an object or a supporter
but we do have the agent leslie short
so if you could turn your camera on
please
can you hear me we can welcome
and you have three minutes to address
the committee i'm going to say what i
was going to say but i would imagine
that
i can address several of the points that
have been raised by members
in questions afterwards so good morning
members of the committee
i'm leslie short of artisan planning i
represent the developer lend x limited a
local builder with a growing reputation
for the delivery of quality housing and
the proposal before you today is no
exception huge amount of time resource
and energy
together with technical design skills
has been employed to bring about just 18
dwellings
on a site which is already allocated in
all the relevant development plans
it is perhaps an example of how
difficult it is and how much resources
required
to address the ongoing problem of
housing need delivered through planning
permissions
it may only be 18 dwellings but that's a
significant contributions to the
districts and more importantly
debenham's housing needs landex and his
development team have addressed
thoroughly and comprehensively every
aspect of this development in this
application for planning permission
which is a full planning application and
the company looks forward to the day
when after several years of preparation
to being able to get on with the
construction and delivery of both the
market and affordable housing comprised
within the scheme
the scheme contains a good mix of
dwelling types designed to address
identified need and for the first time
for a very long time in my experience
this is the first application i've seen
where the numbers of bungalows to be
delivered equals the numbers of houses
and thus addresses the needs of specific
groups of the population
so in summary i say to you this is a
well-designed scheme
seeks to address the constraints and
opportunities that the site offers and
poses
coupled with delivery from our clients
land decks we look forward to the
realization of a high quality housing
development
that we in the village of debenham can
be proud of i do hope that this
committee shares that view
and approves the scheme today so happy
to answer any questions
thank you very much uh questions from
members
uh yeah counselor guthrie oh yes good
morning mr short
um thank you very much um can you just
explain
how much of the hedge in feet and inches
or centimeters because i'm not quite in
that game
um you will be removing to widen low
road
thank you
i will need the assistance of daniel
with some of his plans probably the
landscaping plan
is a good place to start you do that
daniel
it's just there are a lot of sort of
personal houses
on that road that are actually on the
road absolutely
so this is the i'll i'll address the
question in two parts the first is
in relation to the site specific area
and i hope it's reasonably clear
from the master plan in front of you
that the
existing trees and hedge line in the
olive green
color shown on this plan are that which
is to be retained
the section of hedging which is to be
removed you can see is covered
and trees and is covered by the light
green area where the access is proposed
to go through
and the replacement landscaping is shown
just behind it which is new hedging
going in here
now to answer the second part of the
question which was the road widening
off-site um i don't know whether you've
got that plan daniel
but the answer to your question is the
road widening off site which is at the
top of
which is further up towards the village
these plans are all submitted detailed
plans showing the exact extent of the
highway to be widened
are shown are submitted and available on
the website and have been since day one
on the width of the road at um
daniel i don't know whether you can put
your cursor onto the plan please
i'll daniel
it's not that plan that you've got site
access plan
it's not at a particularly good scale
this plan but right at the top
you see a line which is a thicker black
line
offsite towards the village center and
the road winding is to take place on the
southern side of low road
and if my memory serves me correctly the
increased
width or the road widening at that point
is never more than 500 millimeters
uh may i just come back chair so
yeah please do um yes uh thank thank you
mr short i mean you very kindly sent me
an enlarged
um paper copy some months ago
but i just want i just wanted the
committee to be aware of what to the
extent
uh it's quite negligible really um of of
what you're able to do i mean
you've got your constraints thank you
for the answer thank you
uh it's not it's not just what we're
able to do it's being conscious of the
character and design of low road
and what's necessary and the design has
resulted from
several hours of discussion with the
highway authority thank you
thank you very much any other questions
uh for the agent
nope okay thank you very much mr short
well just make one comment which i think
is the same
i'm sorry if members don't ask a
question directly you've had the three
minutes
thank you um okay so
councillor guthrie is the ward member
over to you
thank you um right
well here we are again with a made
neighborhood plan
site allocations in both neighborhood
plan and joint local plan
and a planning application before us and
mid suffolk district council having a
five-year land supply
it's true to say that people near the
application site aren't happy with the
situation
but this has all been through a local
referendum and it is an allocated site
on the face of it it would appear to
tick all the boxes
but does it throughout the initial
approach the proposal and layout has
been improved
with only 18 houses and as we understand
six affordable
when the site was judged to be able to
take up to 35 properties
and on the face of it this is a nice
scheme and the application would seem
reasonable with a good mix of properties
nicely spaced we have had a late
objection from mr rogerson and helen
oust um regarding the overlooking of
their property
but in planning terms i'm not sure that
that would be
uh appropriate well it is to them
of course the cherry tree farmhouse
loses quote its last remnant of its
connection to the surrounding
countryside
deemed by the heritage team to be low
level level of less than substantial
harm
i'm not sure that owner sees it that way
and why
just because there are other surrounding
constraints should we put the final nail
in the
coffin perhaps a more detailed
landscaping could be incorporated if
members were minded to approve
flooding is a big issue in debenham and
we've already heard we haven't had the
photographs
and it really is a shame that you
couldn't really appreciate both the site
and the narrowness of the road
and where this bit uh i allude to
is that the water levels on low road
of recent date have made it impassable
at the other end of low road i will
grant you and near the bridge at the
cherry tree has nearly been overtopped
by running water
the water then runs under the road
adjacent to the cherry tree
and a local land owner did some work on
the water course
and the environment agency went out and
although
the work was not sanctioned it was felt
that the owner would be held responsible
if any undermining of the river on the
curve occurred and this is only
four or 500 yards away from this but the
culvert that this
development is on would run into that
has that been taken into account
i know the eei would have preferred
quote modelling of the culvert
but seemingly happy with the mitigation
which has been provided
and members have asked can a safe
dry escape route be identified
because although they say that they can
get to the piece of land which would
join through to deb three
it currently would go straight on to a
plowed field
there are no footpaths up there
in short a shortfall of early years
schooling exists
and an appropriate payment is requested
to mitigate it
and i say all these things because we
have members of the public listening and
people not understanding
how some of their concerns are addressed
and i know you as counsellors in the
report will do that
the officer and i both have to keep up
to date
debenham is a core village not a key
service center
but indeed has many services and shops
the doctors
are just on low road and the one
photograph that we did see
where there was some cars parked along
on the left hand side
is exactly where the doctors are they're
in an old house
and that's one of the concerns of the
residents not just for appointments but
the location on low road
currently in the covered lockdown and
different working pack for our local gp
practice cars are at a minimum however
with the old cherry tree pub now a vets
their car park is full
and many cars park on that narrow link
road and the narrow part of low road
so when the gps return to seeing their
patients in surgery there will be even
more congestion
in addition if you wish to go to the
high street by car
turning at the junction again
unfortunately we can't see it but it's
by the
dentists if you turn left you take your
life into your own hands
it's a blind junction and often with
delivery vans and lorries parked on the
other side of the road delivering to the
antique restoration facility
and there have been accidents there and
only last year an ambulance was called
but highways stick to the national rules
of severe
and they don't think extra traffic here
would be severe
but that brings me nicely onto the
debenham neighborhood plan
recently lauded and given second place
nationally
planning and this committee should be
guided by our made neighborhood plan
policy deb forbes quite explicit no
exit onto low road and the inspector
concurred with this
at the time of making of the plan it had
been approved and adopted
the covenant holding up any development
on the offside ipswich road
dead 3 and adjacent to this site was not
known
that said the jlp has until 2037 when
that is finally adopted
for this site to come forward and the
other side
one might say well let's just do a
temporary exit and when the site becomes
available the exit can be closed new one
made
and that's fine and we can leave it for
foot and cycles
but that's making an awful lot of
assumptions will this developer be the
winning applicant for that site
if not would that applicant want their
site to be a route through
would it be held as a ransom strip as
sarah mansell has brought up
as a committee and i feel reluctant to
say this
you should do what it says on the tin
and refuse the application
on the clear made instructions and
policies of the debenham
neighborhood plan and refuse the
application thank you
thank you very much classical we have
some questions for you it looks like uh
councillor matheson then councillor
hadingham do you have questions for the
ward member
yeah excuse me do you think it would be
helpful if the chair agreed to
a 10-minute recess while the officers
got some um google google um street view
scenes up so that we could see low road
i i do you know
use lower road to the low road to reach
devon when i visit it and i know that
what you've said is
is true it is it is a frequently
congested and
not a brilliant road really would that
help
would the chair agree to it
anything to to give you members comfort
that you're making your decision on all
the information available but that's up
to the chair
if he thinks that's sufficient then well
i don't think we need ten minute break
if officers can see what they can get
together
why we keep taking other questions um
and see what they come back with and if
it's not enough then we'll
we can always go to a quick break
counselor
oh i was gonna say pretty much the same
thing could we see this blind junction
that kathy talks about and whether
exactly where the doctors
is yeah that's the doctors and the
dentist the doctor
i mean we need to be careful because the
highways comments are in the reports
obviously yeah but i think but it's just
like i say it shows us you know i sort
of vaguely know devlin but i don't know
this low road
okay and council stringer
uh thank you chair yeah obviously uh my
question is about
the the neighborhood plan in dead four
it
rightly it says that there should be no
access onto low road
is there uh any traffic assessment
within the appendices of that
neighborhood plan
that would show us where that that
position comes from
i honestly can't answer that question
i'm sorry
sorry okay
okay um councillor field
not quite sure the appropriate point i
just wanted to
make clear that i didn't look at the
agent's name when i read these papers
i do know mr short not
well and not as a great buddy he does
live in balaam the same village as i am
in
and i've recently been resisting uh
a different application of his i just
want to make it
interesting it's non-pecuniary i don't
think it influenced
his decisions in any significant way but
members and the public should be aware
thank you i'll just quickly join in
chair to say i
agree with you this is clearly a
non-pecuniary interest that need in
trouble council feel he has now properly
declared it
thank you very much okay um so have we
got
daniel pictures more pictures you can
put up from google earth or from a
better road map
that we could show the positioning of
and if if you look where it says low
road and the cream
bungalow and the pink the pink is the um
dentist and if you're coming up the
other way into high street which is at
the bottom of the picture and to the
right
you can actually see there is a lorry
parked
on the opposite side at the that's
correct thank you and that's part there
and
when you come out in a car here you
cannot see around that corner
um you know and there's there's all
sorts of traffic there but
but that's not this applicant's um he's
not here to sort that out i'm merely
pointing it out
you see you come up there and yeah and
you you just can't see around that
corner
but but and then could you go back a
little to the to the water course where
i was
so if you go back up low road yeah keep
going up there keep going stop
the um fire engines are on your right
and if you turn
left if you go to the sorry the other
way
keep going um uh wait a minute
well that's no longer there um i'm
trying to get to the other angle near
the cherry tree do you know where the
cherry tree is yeah
so i'll just keep going to the junction
and then turn left
there you go now turn left down that
road on the left
and that takes you down to the cherry
tree and there's the watercourse
okay now left there and then that's the
other way into the side and there's the
cherry tree down there
on the right and if you keep going just
a little further down that little
lane there if you could if you'd be so
kind
sorry is this where it floods kathy that
sort of
river there right yeah but but well not
actually on that junction it's further
on in that triangle between the dentists
and the cherry tree but
but that that's that has been rare but
the low road has flooded at the other
end to get out the other way i'm just
making you aware there is a flood issue
and
if they're not going to do what it was
to the culvert the the the floods
appear to appear to be satisfied with
what they've got but
um there's a blood here where you just
see that
no no you need to swing it round to the
right again sorry
but anyway yeah keep going work keep
going keep going a bit more
and stop and where on the
left i think there's a bridge by that um
the big chestnut tree people will walk
across there but it floods all
across there hasn't flooded off recent
date but it's been nearly over to
just above the sign is a little bridge a
footway
and the water is nearly over top that
but i don't know how it would react with
further um
whatever the mitigations are whether it
would be satisfactory
we've got some more questions councilor
mayor
thanks chip council guthrie you
are asking us to reject um this
application
um on access grounds but the the parish
councils seem to take a more
um flexible approach in that they ask
for
um the access to low road must only be
temporary
if we are mindful to approve do you see
that your position
is at odds with the parish council no
because i've been listening to what the
parish council and the local residents
have been saying
but i but i i on the face of it as i
said right at the beginning that the
whole
site ticks all the boxes but it is
dead against the neighbor the
neighborhood plan that's the problem
because if you look at the parish
council's last response
they are saying that it's against their
neighborhood plan but
but debenham does want development
there's no two ways about it
i'm just i'm just doing what people have
to ask me to
represent them on councillor field
does anybody have any view of the return
period of
flooding in the area particularly near
the site
you know does it is it a once a year
event or once every
10 years event or whatever do we know
what that figure is
[Music]
i i haven't personally got details but i
have seen over the last
last year a low road has flooded in two
places
but this is that all this would
contribute to i don't know if the floods
are
satisfied with what's being mitigated
it's not for me to say
i'm not the expert but i've seen it
flood
daniel do you want to come in with any
uh views on what
what the floods team have said on that
please
yes thank you so i'm just getting up
there so
the site is part of um flood zone two
and three
so flood zone two is land having between
a one in one hundred and one in one
thousand
annual probability of flooding um
flood zone three is land having a one in
one hundred or greater
annual probability of flooding um
so that is the that is the definition um
of risk that we have from the flood
zones um in terms
of um the comments from the flood and
water management team
they're content that the details have
been brought forward in the application
are sufficient to mitigate and deal with
the flood risk from the flood zones to
and through the frontage of the site
thank you okay any other questions for
councillor guthrie
no okay thank you very much thank you
thank you okay um so that's all the
information before us
it's now up to us to debate discuss and
to reach a conclusion
over to members council guthrie if you
just take your hand down
for us please as well thank you
councillor matheson
um yeah i i thought it would be helpful
just to just
to start by looking at what the parish
council actually said and i think
the um
they are the the um the temp
then removing the temporary access to
low road etcetera
that is essentially a full back position
if we are minded to approve really if
you read the detail on page 195
what they said so i think we um
they are basically they objecting
so so i think i just wanted to be clear
about that yes listen to other members
thank you council matheson next up is
councillor miller
thank you chair uh i fully appreciate to
everything that's been said
and i think i'd like to make a positive
point towards this the suffolk
constabulary did actually make a number
of
recommendations in the paper they
submitted as a console t
and looking at the plans that have been
shown to us i do believe these have
actually been taken into into
consideration
so i think that is a really positive
point with this particular layout
of these houses and bungalows thank you
chair
thank you very much cancer stringer
thank you chair this is a relatively
difficult one because but then that's
why it's here
i actually think we're on an interesting
horns of a dilemma
because uh neighborhood plans don't have
to show
land assemblage packages uh and sort of
past deliverability tests
uh in terms of the housing you you can
end up
with situations like this where there
aren't agreement between landowners uh
and what would normally happen in the
very distant
past if if there were landowners of
housing that we all agreed needed to
come forward
often the local authority would step in
to become the honest broker so you
didn't end up with people having ransom
strips
and i think that's what we're being
asked to do here i mean almost in a way
we're being asked to approve a planning
application
that in one element disagrees with the
neighborhood plan
to it to try and enact a policy of the
neighborhood plan
because it's my understanding about
there is no land assemblage agreement
here between the two parties
and at the moment there is a road
there's a route
to delivering this but in order to
deliver it
we have to go against for a undefined
period of time
against one of the conditions of the
neighborhood plan where all i can say at
the moment that there is no master plan
for this area
so it makes it
really really difficult uh i i
i'm minded to approve this in the in the
way that it's
set because i see no i can see problems
if we don't
if we don't approve this and and housing
delivery becomes difficult because of
economic reasons
we could be sitting here a few years
time with no houses being delivered
and we're losing our five-year land
supply they were a totally different
area
uh and i get the sensitivity of of
this neighborhood plan wishing there not
to be an access here
for cars i get that but enable to get to
a position
where there are no access for cars we
may have to approve this
in this form and allow mid suffolk with
the provider the mid-suffolk is that
honest broker
so that land doesn't become a ransom
strip to deliver that
policy finally for that neighborhood
plan thank you chair
thank you councilman
uh thank you chair i i i wholeheartedly
agree
with uh with council stringer's comments
because
on the face of it i think this does look
like a reasonable
application uh but we have this one
sticking point
and in fact councillor matheson's
comment about the parish council
yes they are objected to it but they
also
see that they've got this fallback
position that should we be minded to
approve this that access onto low road
um is eventually stopped up and i so
long as we can
guarantee that is going to happen and if
if that means mitzvah has to step in and
buy the land or whatever they have to do
then i think this might be the
compromise that we
we have to take however if we are minded
to approve
um as well as a condition that i think
has already been mentioned about the
sustainability schemes
uh i would also like to see a condition
about the ducting
for ev charging for those properties
that don't have a parking spot outside
their house
thank you uh sorry council guthrie i
can't bring you back in because it's
only
it's we're in debate now i noticed your
hands up
no that was from before i'm so sorry
okay they're from
um i don't have any hands out so i'll
just add my pennies worth then i
uh i agree with councillor stringer and
with council mansell
we're absolutely in a bind on this um
for me this is really messy actually um
we're being asked to prove something
that's only going to be temporary that's
reliant on someone else bringing forward
another site that
as has been said we don't know if it's
viable
we're being asked to direct traffic
across a
area that floods on floods frequently
and i i
uh i'm in and out of debenham a lot
and low road floods a lot uh i say a lot
i mean you know
it could be this week it could be next
week it may not be this year but it does
flood
um and i'm really sorry to interrupt
um we've just lost councillor matheson
so we'll just have to pause briefly
otherwise he won't be able to take
um because we need to make sure he hears
all the information before members when
coming to the decision
okay i'll just wait for mandy to
right well if he is it could take him
five or ten minutes what i suggest we do
is no discussions please and we'll start
again at 11 35 so that we can find him
and everyone can have a quick
quick 10 minute break so we'll start
again at 11 35.
so council madison are you back with us
yeah yes chair i am i i got um
as far as councillor stringing string of
being on the halls of my
dilemma and then uh teams failed and
then it dragged my whole computer down
um and to the point where i had to send
away the
error messages and reboot it so all the
rest of it so
yes i'm now fully working again but okay
so you missed
you missed uh just before me was
counsellor mansell
yeah i did miss councillor manchester
united would you just like to give a
quick summary of what you said
just for the benefit of counseling uh
yeah i i basically said that i
agreed with councillor stringer uh that
we were in a bit of a dilemma
um because it seemed that it was a
compromise to
allow planning on this site before the
dev3
site but i also said that if we were
minded to
approve i would like to see a condition
about ducting
for ev charging points for those people
who don't have a parking space right
outside their house
thank you that's helpful thank you do we
need to do a roll call
uh robert or are we happy
do we just get everyone turn the camera
on just to show they're here that's
gonna say if that's easy to chair that
yeah could everyone just turn their
camera on just so we know all members
are back
or present and correct robert yep the
only person i can't see is councillor
had
having him but i think it's because
there's only so many we can have on the
screen we're having them
are you present i am here i am here
we're done apologies counselor and thank
you thanks everyone
okay so we'll continue so just after
councillor manson went i went i was just
starting
john when we got to the point where we
realized you'd been cut off so
um basically what i was just about to
say was that um this is a real
pickle this application to me um
it doesn't work for several reasons
uh in many ways because what we're being
asked to do is to prove something on the
basis that something may happen next
door in the future to allow us
to deliver a transport and access to the
site through a route that we all know is
better
and preferred low road does flood
it's a it's not a great access point um
we know up
uh um further along low road does flood
towards the dentists
um and uh so those things feel messy
also mid suffolk is being asked to step
in to look at
by taking on some land when we have a
policy of not wanting to take on land at
the moment and actually reduce our
exposure and reduce risk
um so for me uh and then the pedestrian
cycle access is going to be very
important but obviously we've been told
that can be conditioned
but it just it just feels
not quite right to me i don't know why
i'm i'm not that content so i'll see
what other members have to say
uh councillor field you were next
yes i'm afraid i i find
that um really this is a fairly small
site
uh so there are traffic issues on on low
road um
and indeed further deeper into debenham
yes there are
issues there that have been there for
some time and and will remain
i don't personally find that sufficient
to
to block development at this site but i
accept the
the parish's wishes for foreign
exit from it to be via the the other deb
three site
um one has to ask when that will come
forward and clearly it's a financial
constraint on it no
nothing else it's it's a defined site
and
the financial difficulty uh will
disappear within a relatively short
number of years
no reason actually why do planning et
cetera shouldn't carry on while while
that period expires so
i'm inclined to think my view is that
that site probably will come forward
the issue with flooding um is an issue
of the road floods
um you know how occasionally as you're
implying sort of
once a year maybe um
flood zone three but it's not an issue
of
houses on if built here will get you
inundated or
or anything remotely like that the site
seems to be above the
area that floods um so
and debenham needs development as as the
the member the local member said so i'm
inclined to feel i'm fairly
relaxed about this um i do
take counselor mansell's view that
we need to make sure that there is a
capability to
put in additional car charging points
without the cost of you know digging up
the vast areas of road or whatever so
we've thought a bit ahead on that and i
think with that
provision then i would be very happy to
see this go ahead
thank you councillor phil councillor
mayor
thank you chair um
[Music]
i don't see um
a problem with this site as long as
the access is conditioned
to allow no permanent vehicle access
onto low road
now i'm not sure what permanent means
you know is it going to be five years
is it going to be 10 years what happens
if the other site doesn't come
to fruition um so
i believe the parish council recognized
that there's an issue and they've
in their response they've highlighted
that
they would if we're mindful to approve
accept access onto low road
and highways in their assessment don't
believe that this small site accessing
onto
low road would cause any additional
issues
so i think i would be mindful to approve
as long as we can condition
the access is removed when the new site
comes on stream
but having said that i can see in the
future we're actually creating more
problems
because when we try and close off or
when that access is closed off i have a
sneaking suspicion that many of the
residents in the site that we're
considering today
will be very upset and then there'll be
another
wrangle that will take place to whether
they should be or shouldn't be closed
off
but that's a planning issue for another
day
so on balance i think i am mindful to
um support approval of this application
thank you matheson
yeah i'm i'm i must say i'm not very
keen on
on this i think really um
flood flood risk yes yes they've done
all the assessments
and there will be a plan and so on and
so on but i think we know that
year by year the flood incidence of
flooding is
is worsening and
um as far as it being a temper
a temporary road access um it's a
permanent road access until
until it isn't any longer um so
it is permanent if the other one doesn't
come forward for whatever reason
so i i think because of the the flooding
and the uncertainty uh i'm i'm very
reluctant and i will probably think of
voting against
thank you councillor muller thank you
chair
having listened to to the debate uh and
i do agree this is quite a messy
application but i think just on balance
i think i'm more inclined to approve
this application
than reject it chair thank you
well we don't have any proposals yet
just so
we're clear no one's put a proposal in
uh council stringer than councillor
muller
yep uh not wishing to
uh uh shrink the amount of christmas
cards that may or may not come through
my door
uh i think that on balance i will
to move the debate on as well move
approval on this uh
it's not with glee because there is one
element
of this application that goes against an
agreed neighborhood plan
having said that from all of the
evidence that i have looking at all of
the evidence
including what we've submitted in our
joint local plan
at the moment we've suggested this site
in our joint local plan consultation
is quote available if we now
say it isn't available uh it's going to
cause us difficulties
and debenham difficulties further down
the line if
we cannot demonstrate that it is
even though it's in a form that the
neighborhood plan
didn't agree to but this may well be the
only route we can
deliver the wishes and aspirations of
that neighborhood plan
and i think with some controls put in
i.e
mid-suffolk being that honest broker
over that quote ransom strip
i think we may stand a better chance of
delivering the outcomes of that
neighbourhood
plan than if we didn't uh
so like i say it isn't with glee that
i've moved
approval but i honestly think that we
are
our officers are trying to deliver two
different things at the same time
they're trying to deliver
because they've got it in the report and
they're trying to get those aspirations
of that neighborhood plan
front and center here but equally with
the demands of the mppf
that says that we'll engage positively
with developers
to bring about positive housing outcomes
uh and it's
that little tip of the balance that
suggests that i will i would be happy to
move
approval in this case thank you chair
thank you and
and do you just want to comment on the
access and the cycle ways
absolutely the the the access at the
rear obviously
in any event will be open for cycles and
pedestrians
and for emergency vehicles i think
that's actually something that we we do
uh
forget at times to have a secondary act
if this whole site ends up getting built
like we
like we think it will i think a
secondary access in the back in there
for emergency vehicles
could well be a bonus certainly knowing
that
part of this area is liable to flooding
of course and i take that
all into account but i think going
through what we've been through i think
uh
yeah i'll be happy to move approval in
this case thank you
and can i just ask what about the legal
obligation that the parish council has
asked regarding pedestrian
cycle access so we we put that as a
legal obligation
yeah yeah yeah happy with that chair
okay uh councilman muller
thank you chair um i think counter
string has made some very very valid
points so i'm happy to second his
approval thank you chair
thank you um councillor mansell
uh thank you chair i just wanted to know
where we
where we are standing with any
additional conditions
with this proposal from councillor
stringer uh regarding the sustainability
and the ev power ducting whether they
were included or not
i i thought it was taken as read that
they were included sorry i should have
mentioned it yes i want to include those
conditions
as we've discussed during the debate on
sustainability and
ducting for ev charging points thank you
can i run through those quickly
would that be all right so we've got a
condition should we just should we just
double check see if anyone else is
adding anything and then of course
all right um councillor mayor is that an
old hand or did you want to come in
counselor hattingham oh it's just a bit
of a stupid question really will it be
down to the developer to tell the people
that buy these houses that that that
entrance is going to be stopped up is
that something that they have to do sort
of by law or do they not have to
i don't think there would be any
specific requirement for them to do that
but i think we touched earlier
and this is what i wanted to come to
about an informative detailing the
potential access arrangements for deb
iii if that comes forward um and also i
was kind of minded to suggest that
perhaps we just clarify the section 106
proposal slightly that that will have
some reference to dealing with how the
access is expected to be closed if deb3
comes forward
so that that is um enshrined in that way
so general do you just want to run
through
the recommendations now then please yep
so we've got the recommendation for
approval on page 190 291
and then we've got additional conditions
for a scheme of sustainable and
renewable energy measures
to be agreed including a scheme for
um electric vehicle parking including
ducting
then we've got an informative detailing
the access arrangement if deb three
comes forward
and then the matching part to that one
that the section 106 will have
a mechanism for dealing with how that's
expected to happen whether that's us
taking on the land
some management opportunities that can
be um you know
agreed through the section 106 process
but we would have some expectation of
doing that
under the section 106. so they were the
additions i had noted
okay thank you are you happy with that
counselor stringer
very happy chair and the secondary
councilor miller
i too i'm happy with that chair thank
you okay
so on that basis and this uh john
matheson councilman you have your hand
up
yeah i did a long time ago i did spot
that the
biodiversity of recommendations had
admitted swift bricks which we think is
one of the simplest and cheapest things
to include
so please can we include them
council stringer councillor mayor your
view yeah happy birthday
sorry councilman yes happy with that
thank you so we'll add those
okay anything else i think that's it
then so there is a proposal
uh we now ask the chief planning officer
just to um
well i think we already have really uh
to run through i don't think we need to
do that again i think that's been clear
to us so
i'll move straight on to ask the
governance officer to conduct an
electronic vote
thank you chair i'm just putting the
final touches into the electronic vote
after the points that members have
raised so i will be with you in two
seconds
apologies for any spelling mistakes in
there
so if members could go to the
same point before in modern.gov and i
will
open the vote now
so we just got one person who hasn't
voted
thank you chair so the resolution is
carried by six votes to two
okay thank you very much okay we'll now
move on to the next
uh agenda item which is uh dc
203632 i will stand down
being the local ward member and hand the
chair over to councillor dave muller
councillor muller over to you thank you
very much councillor hicks
um i would now like to invite the case
officer
jamie martin edwards please to introduce
the application to the committee
please thank you thank you very much
chair
i will just start sharing uh the
presentation if you could all just let
me know when you can see that clearly
you can see that you can see that jamie
yeah thank you
perfect thank you very much i'll begin
the presentation now
this application is for land east of
abbey hill in hoxen
this follows on from an outline
application that was approved by the
district council
in 2017. you may remember
as pointed out at the beginning of the
committee this application was before
members
in the summer around august time for the
reserve matters for four dwellings the
original outline application was for
up to four and this is a revised scheme
after the application was refused
so the reserve matters like i said is
for three dwellings this time
and this includes access appearance
landscaping
layout and scale
so first of all just an aerial map of
the site i will
span out from here but this is the site
here and i think what's
a good idea to start with is it will be
a lot more clearer when we go through
the slides but the
monument which is a material
consideration in this instance
is just below my cursor just here i'll
just move it so it's
nice and easy to see so just zooming out
uh we've got oxen in two parts we've got
a northern part of hodgson
and a southern part both having their
own separate settlement boundaries
and the site sits in the middle
and just the red line plan and again
just highlighting there that they've got
st
edmunds monument on the right hand side
of the site
i'll also say that you've got abby hill
road which runs
following my cursor now and there's also
reference made within the
report of a public right of way
and that goes back on itself to the
north here
runs off to the right
so just a little bit more detail in
regards to the constraints of the area
so the green line at the top here
outlines the settlement boundary for the
northern part of oxen
the pink line on this side outlines the
settlement boundary
for the southern part of oxen we can see
here the red line of the site abutting
that settlement boundary
the purple line on the south and the
purple line on the north
indicates the con conservation area
we've just highlighted clearly there
that the saint edmunds monument
is selected here and we've also got the
flood zone risk areas of one uh sorry
two and three
highlighted in blue and also just note
some other listed buildings in the area
we've got a grade two
star listed um abbey farmhouse
we also have the grade two listed wall
another listed building in here and
we've got two listed buildings just down
the bottom here both grade
two
another constraints map just
highlighting all of this green area is a
special landscape area
tried not to put too many constraints on
one map just so we can see them
individually
and again this is just highlighting all
the constraints we've just gone through
in a more standardized map format
so green area is your special landscape
area the site clearly sits outside of
that
but does have some interaction with it
so i'm going to move on to the actual
block plan i think this is a good place
to start
we've got the monument which is grade 2
listed i think it's key to notes at this
stage when the outline application
was approved this
monument was not listed the listing came
after
the outline application was approved in
2017
uh i will also start a move on sorry
next to the accesses
so we've got two accesses one into plot
one
which is here and one access into plot
twos and three this is a shared access
the outline application originally had
this access
uh slightly more to the north this has
been
moved as to have two plots served by one
access
it needs to meet certain highway
standards originally that was a little
bit
skinnier or slimmer that access in
essence could only serve one plot
which was fine at the time however if we
want it
to just serve one plot that means the
subsequent plot needs to be served off
this access
which means that it would cross over the
path
which i'll come onto a second the path
but on balance we felt
that to widen this axis to make sure it
serves two plots rather than just one
mitigating the need for a secondary axis
to cross over the path to serve the
other plot
on balance it means that we are going to
have to lose
an ash tree here t2 tree that is however
going to be replaced
with another tree here so on balance we
felt that that is acceptable
so we'll move on to the path next
currently there is a permissible path
existing all the way up to the monument
this application as part of a section
106
agreement will secure that path in
perpetuity however it will only secure
it between
the red line areas from this boundary
where the red line finishes up to the
monument
we can't secure that that's outside of
the redline plan and also in a different
ownership so we can't reasonably secure
that
therefore the public benefit that's been
attributed to that
is only associated with this area and
not this area here this will remain as a
permissive path
you'll also notice that we have a wide
area
in the internal center of the ax site
which is for open space originally the
application
offered to use this as part of a
confidence under plot one that they will
be the owners of this and will need to
maintain
it however we don't have as a planning
authority any control over a confidence
and felt that inappropriate in this
instance and therefore it will be part
of a section 106
which will be agreed afterwards should
this application be approved
excuse me um i'll just also note then
we've got plot one
which is uh this kind of l shape
here and we've got plots turn three
kind of standard format of a shape of a
house there
we've also got their subsequent garages
individually detached
and this one over here
and also just to say in terms of the
open space area we'll be looking to
control this fire and maintenance
condition
also just note as well that if i zoom in
a little bit
which hopefully you can do there we've
got some
blue lines through here which show
we've got one meter post and rail
fencing that will go all the way around
this plot
skin post and rail fencing along the
path
and around the areas of plots one and
two
excuse me we do also have close boarded
fencing
in this area here here and here and
that's obviously to secure
amenity areas within these plots
let's move on to the next slide this is
plot one
this has had some revisions to it uh
which i can come on to if if necessary
uh originally under the scheme that we
saw in august it was
um all of single story height
we'll notice now on this element we now
have
a one and a half story this is in
essence 50 centimeters higher in ridge
height
so we have this element here being 6.5
meters
there's 1.5 with living accommodation in
the roof
whereas this area here we're looking at
six meters we're talking about a 50
centimetre difference
to allow for an extra space of living
accommodation in this roof area
these are plots two and three and i'll
just flick back to two
uh they're very similar in design and um
[Music]
kind of matching in in character we've
got some detailing
around the barge boards above the
windows we've got a
plinth um bit more of a character of
with the oak porch as well
uh and we've got a chimney please note
though that the chimney obviously
doesn't actually have any working order
inside it
merely is for decorative reasons
and again you can see this plot in terms
of how it's laid out
plot 3 is very much just a mirror image
of that
these are the carports for plots two and
three very modest in scale
for one parking space the store area at
the rear
this is the garage for plot one again
two bays on this one
garden store traditional materials being
used
tree survey plan in front of us here
just indicating this will be controlled
by condition
and shows where the protective fencing
will be going during construction phases
to ensure that we don't have any um
adverse impacts to the tree root
canopies
of the trees that will be remaining so
we've got that tree there remaining
naturally they're remaining in this one
and you'll remember from the previous
slides there is an ash tree to come out
there
and a replacement tree to go in its
place once the development is done
and just before i do the comparison
between these i also should just note
up here this this is the plan that we're
looking at today as part of our
consideration the one on the right hand
side is what came before
members committee back in august so i'll
go for that in a second
but just to indicate that we've got t5
t6 and t7
these are three trees that are indicated
as being new planting
in here as a subsequent sort of um
shielding to plot one uh but notice
obviously around where t4 is
an existing tree this is all kept open
to secure the views
into the monument as part of this open
space
so just in comparison to what you
obviously saw and refused at committee
back in august
uh the two plots of two and three these
were 8.5 meter high dwellings
these were large dwellings at the front
they were orientated in a way to provide
a sense of place
giving a centerpiece in terms of the
access to the path
in this instance we've got rid of those
two out the front and
really enhance this area here to provide
us a real open space
and secure this two plots facing down
abby hill and again securing that kind
of sense of place that we were trying to
achieve in the first instance
but just making it more open and setting
of the listed building which is off this
site here but is approximately here if
we use the left hand
plan as an indicator
so just to confirm uh the differences uh
plot one originally 6.2 meters tall
235 square meters when we look back in
august
now we're looking at only six meters
tall at the single story level
whereas the 1.5 is 6.5 meters
at 253 square meters and then plot 2 and
3 is where we're seeing a significant
drop in
in sizes as you see plots two and three
were
eight point five meters tall plot four
being eight point four meters tall
single story element now is down to five
point seven meters
and each individual house is 106 square
meters this is merely just to show a
comparison of what you saw back in
august compared to what the developer is
bringing forward to us now
so just to run through some photos you
may remember some of these photos from
last time
this arrow here we used as part of the
committee last time just to indicate
there's a bit of a space here
we predicted that we would probably see
the roof lines of the large 8.5 houses
in this area which would kind of
correspond with the development line
in there and wouldn't look out of place
but obviously now we've gone through to
uh single story elements this will still
stay as a
kind of no uh built form in this area
and this
arrow here just indicates the stairs
that goes up
into the site towards to get to the
monument across the site here
you'll notice in this area here the
photos will show where they've been
taken from
with this arrow so just moving a little
bit forward you can just start to see
the handrail of the stairs that goes up
you can see the oak tree that's going to
remain and you can also see the ash tree
that's going to come out
to allow for the access to go in
and we can just see behind that the
other ash tree which is going to remain
is standing right in front of the uh
stairs this photo was taken i believe
just
around about june time um you can see
here that obviously the site is
a bit of shrubs that have been growing
in currently you can't see
the uh monument almost like a
strategically police
placed shrub there but i can assure you
that in later parts of the year which
you will see in a second
in the absence of this the monument you
can be seen directly here
so walking up the stairs and into the
site and still looking across to the
uh east the monument is is clear there
and again walking across at the time
there was a kind of two meter mode
grass area allowing the permissible path
through and obviously with the
shrublands growing here there's a
monument up front
um and close this is exactly what it
looks like and again
just off to the left along down this end
which you can just see the edge of here
obviously you've got the special
landscape area
so the monument is behind me here in
this photo
and this is just to clearly indicate two
uh tea tree four
and the other the oak tree and the other
ash tree these all to remain
and this is the one that's due to come
out to allow for that excess to come in
and prevent the third plot being
accessed
from this access and crossing the path
so again just noticing here where we're
looking we're within the site and we're
looking straight down abbey road hill
you can just see a cyclist there going
down
just to give an indication obviously
again the special landscape area in the
background
the traditional forms the timber the pan
tiles
which the garages and carports in this
application seek to sort of
um mimic
we're now down abbey hill road here
looking up and i've indicated the arrow
there
i think if i zoom in you can't quite see
it in this instance i have to admit
though when you're on site
the camera doesn't do it justice you can
see the the uh monument there
it must be shown though that obviously
where plot one will go
that view will be lost to the monument
moving up again this is summer time so
this is is heavily grown
this looks definitely different in the
winter time obviously it's shielded
during this period of the year
and just moving closer to the site we
start to move past this
verdant area and you can see
where plots two and three will be you'll
probably see
just the edge of plot three there and
plot two looking down
and giving the indication that we're
going into the site to get to the
monument
i've just moved on to the path here and
out of the road that
summer vegetation you could see is just
in here so i'm right on the edge of it
and again the monument is quite clear
and prominent in this instance
plot one again is going to block this
view from there from here
just moving into the road again you can
still see it so similar location just
stepping out
to give us an idea as you move around
and it's at this point here
the plot one will no longer break the
view of the monument this is where the
open space is going to come in
as you can see we're looking right
across here and this is where plot one
will be moved into the northern part
so we're securing this area it becomes a
lot more uh up front
and again the stairs are just here to
give indication
and this is looking back across the
special landscape area within the site
uh just past the stairs and looking
directly north
and what we can actually see there is
the prow sign that's where the footpath
rolls off
down here and again just to show that
with
different times of the year i've done a
few site visits at this site over the
course of
the last 18 months so again looking over
at the special landscape area
this is winter time this is the monument
back to the monument
and these are the two houses opposite if
you remember when we looked at the tree
line earlier in the summer period these
houses
you can't really see you can just see
the top of rose mountain which is this
one
and grasmere which is over here
obviously winter it's a different
picture
and again winter time it's quite clear
where the monument sits there's actually
a 2017 photo just taken from back when
the outline application
uh was dealt with i think this is a
clear image here that actually
the permissive path at times
agricultural field
could be plowed uh permissive uh path
that sometimes
won't be as inviting as such as what it
could be if it was secured
so i think just before i go through some
of the details of the recommendation i
think
key points to to indicate here is
there's clearly going to be some harm to
the uh monument in terms of its setting
by putting development in this instance
i think the developers have done
um some work there to open up the space
and instead of
creating harm offering some enhancements
to the open space to it
and securing that as part of the section
106. uh
i is part of my report of taking the
harm as being a less
low level of less than substantial uh
our heritage team have indicated it as
almost a neutral impact
on it suffolk preservation as a result
of this
scheme have removed their
reasons for refusal under the scheme
that you saw back in august and actually
is happy with the the open space and
feels that it does enhance the area
but for the purpose of my report we have
looked to uh
say that there is harm and taking that
as a base level of harm
and then it's up to members to really
debate whether or not the public
benefits of securing the path and
securing the open space around it
including the three different how the
three new houses and some landscaping
whether or not that's enough public
benefit to outweigh the harm
as you'll see in the report i felt that
it did
so some late papers obviously gave some
indications of
a objection that we received on sunday
evening just
highlighting and summarizing those
points and indicating with the report
where they've already been covered
and also just to make sure that it is
clear the section 106
will secure this area in the middle not
to plot one in ownership but has an open
space
and a maintenance condition to secure
its ongoing maintenance
thank you happy for taking any questions
counselor matheson yeah i did just want
to
to i'm glad you touched on that that
final point because that i was not clear
initially so it will be an open space
um so who's going to maintain it
um under the um you know you'll propose
106 and so on we'll be looking for a
management company to look after that
um i know that there was indications in
conversation
uh from the agent under the last
application
that if it was approved and the parish
council were interested in taking it on
then they would happily look to
allow that type of transition however i
didn't feel it was appropriate that
stage considering the parish council's
comments to
to pursue um that option uh but as far
as i understand that that still is an
offer
available however if that wasn't the
case then yes it would be a management
company that would take it on and we'd
be dealing with that as part of a
maintenance condition
thank you thank you um i believe
sir uh councillor mansell you are next
please
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
ask about the necessity
for the post and rail fencing either
side of the path
within that open space uh is that
strictly necessary
uh and if so why have we you know why
have we decided to
or why is the applicant decided to put
put that path
restricting it between the fences yeah
um like i said i've done
a fair amount of uh site visits uh to
this area and
two of the site visits actually met
people who were coming from outside the
area to come and visit the monument
um what i found when parking up around
here to come and do the site visit
is these people are actually coming in
here and then just walking across the
site there
rather than the permissible path which
isn't clearly indicated until you
actually get to the steps
i'm not saying that's right nor wrong
not at all i guess the point of the
post-rail fence
is to one direct people across the
actual path and two as you'll see that
this we look to
secure this as a wild flower meadow mix
is to prevent sort of people traipsing
through
uh perhaps damaging what can be a
potential uh
sort of habitat here in terms of uh
insects and vertebrae
okay thank you um catch the phil then
kesler hicks please
just for accuracy looking at your report
power 5.5 you talk about the
various heights the western boundary is
approximately 1.28
centimeter higher than the path in front
of plot
two what's that about the width of my
thumb
is that a correct measurement apologies
can you just say those measurements
again councillor
uh there's there's three lines one talks
about 50 centimeters the other one is
1.28
centimeters and the next one is 1.50
centimeters yeah that's clearly a fault
on my part that needs to be meters
not centimeters apologies thank you
about a thousand times no 100 times
different
thank you thank you actually phil uh
councillor hicks please
thank you can i just ask about the large
tree that's being uh taken out
uh the ash tree um is it a healthy ash
tree or does it have ash diet back
i have no indication that it isn't
health healthier ash tree
i think clearly in the photos uh it's in
full i'll just get the photos up again
so we can see
healthy ash trees are quite rare these
days so it's that's i just want to check
it does look like yes it's a healthy ash
tree
thank you thank you very much
um i have a question um please jamie
can you confirm that the proposed
footpath within the development is that
going to remain a grassed footpath or
would that be concreted or
will it have like shingle a shingle path
like you said mentioned it'll be
maintained under a section 106
agreement i just want to clarify what
type of surface will be on that path i
appreciate
it's going to be sort of a rough era
field area beyond the actual development
but
just for that in that development zone
please yeah of course uh there is no
indication at this stage
um that of exactly what surface that
would be
um if if people are asking my preference
i don't think this should be shingled i
think they should be kept as
a grass area and we've got shingle and
permeable surfaces on the driveways
obviously highway standards this is
going to have to be non-permeable for
these areas with drainage to prevent any
surface water going off down into
the flood risk zones down in abbey at
the bottom of abbey hill road
so yeah i would like to make sure that
this stays as a permeable surface
and i think in terms of the character
and the history of the monument i
personally would like to see this as
being a grass area
as part of the path however if members
felt that it should be shingled to
ensure that you know
people didn't get their boots too muddy
in the winter time i think that's a
reasonable condition that we can put on
if we would rather see a different
surface there
thank you very much do we have any more
questions for the case officer please
yes i i have another one yes thank you
council of field
yes on page 271
um the proposed record conditions
it says removal of permitted development
rights for extensions
outbuildings and fencing i think uh
permitted development is heading for a
situation where you could add an
additional story to
a bungalow are we going to restrict that
as well
yes i think that's a good idea i think
that is
imperative that we do this particularly
for areas like plot one
so we can remove that as part of the
condition include that in there
i believe the the uh
ordinary wording that we would put in is
more of a general removal of all
permitted development rights just
highlighting the most important ones
there but i think you're right that's a
very important one as well so we'll make
sure that that's included should you be
minded to approve the application
thank you very much councillor hicks
then catch the stringer please
coachella hicks did you have another
question
sorry okay thank you uh countless
stringer then please
be a legacy hand there we go uh yeah
could you on this very helpful map here
could you show me where the ash tree
that's due to come out
is by pointing your yep so the green
circle is what is going to be replaced
and the black
dotted circle is what's to be removed
that's
indicating its canopy currently and
that's what's going to be replaced
okay okay so it's on the edge of the uh
of the road well it's in the verge
almost yeah so there's a path here
uh that runs along here uh pedestrian
footpath that goes all the way down the
hill and it's just slightly different
and what would what would be the
consequences if we if we didn't agree to
its removal
if we didn't want it to be removed
they're not going to be able to get this
access into surf two plots they could
get an access in to serve one plot
uh within those two trees um so it'd
then be a case of
well whether one plot remains and they
get rid of the other one and
push it over to this side or vice versa
but yeah i think on balance to ensure
that we don't have any
crossing over of that footpath of an
access
we felt that was acceptable
okay thank you very much countless
stringer do we have any more questions
for the case officer
no then i would now ask the parish
council representative
sarah foote to speak you have three
minutes to address the committee sarah
can you please turn your camera on
please sarah thank you
i have but i think the um presentation
is still on screen
if you can see me would you like me to
remove that or would you like me to keep
it up for the depends how much they want
to see with me jamie
chair yeah yeah i'm happy for you to to
leave that up
if everyone's happy with that uh jamie
thank you thank you okay
thank you very much chair um so i'll
begin by reminding members that in 2017
your council did not have an up-to-date
local plan and could not provide a
five-year land supply
it's still the opinion of the parish
council that this application to build
on
greenfield land which is outside of the
settlement boundary
adjoining the conservation area and
homes as an edmonds monument would never
have been approved if this had been the
case
this was clearly a controversial
application for which numerous
objections were submitted
however it was not dealt with according
to your schema delegation and the
original decision to grant outline
permission was made by one officer
whilst having to accept there will
wrongly be development on this unique
site of great historical interest
the parish council remains committed to
limiting the harmful impact on the
setting of the listed building
and the open countryside to quote one of
the development control committee
members when this application was last
considered in the summer
this clearly should never have been
allowed but we are where we are
so where are we the parish council has
noted the applicant's attempts to try
and mitigate the substantial detrimental
impact
by reducing the scheme to three
dwellings
instead of the four large dwellings
which were refused by yourselves earlier
this year
however the dwelling at plot 1 in the
revised scheme remains too large
the dominance of this dwelling has a
ruinous effect on the landscape
and obscures the views of the listed
monument plot 1 has become an isolated
element rather than part of his scheme
and stands out not only due to its size
but its contrast to the two other
smaller proposed dwellings
there are many policies this application
is contrary to and we ask that you
particularly take into account mppf
127 which states planning decisions
should ensure
that developments are sympathetic to
local character and history
and 130 which calls for permission to be
refused for development of poor design
that fails to take the opportunities
available for improving the character
and quality of the area the parish
council asks that you again refuse this
scheme to do
due to poor design dominant scale and
appearance
and failure to be sympathetic with the
local area and history
and the unnecessary loss of a healthy
tree given the historical significance
of the site
and concurring with earlier comments
made by committee members
the parish council is concerned that a
full archaeological survey has not been
conducted
we ask that you now concur with the
parish council and vote to refuse this
application as currently presented
thank you for your time thank you very
much sarah
do we have any questions um for sarah
please
for members counselor mansell please
thank you chair um i'd just like to ask
uh the parish council representative
uh should uh this planning application
be granted approval are the parish
council
willing to take on the um
open space provision and the main and
the
and the path to get to sin edmunds
monument
um thank you um i am clark to the
council and not a councillor
um i did wonder as the discussion
started if i would get asked that
question
all i can say is on i don't see why not
um the parish council has got other such
similar land that's under its management
and ownership
um and it's something we would certainly
consider we were very keen
um to retain the access to the monument
um but the wildflower area is a new
um edition that the parish council
hasn't actually given specific
consideration to
thank you kate do we have any more
questions for for sarah sarah foote
please
any more questions
no thank you then i would now ask the
objector to speaker mr rob
marsh feely uh you have three minutes to
address the committee mr marsh feeling
could you please turn your camera on
please thank you if you see me and hear
me
um i assume so yes
see you mr marshfield thank you thank
you all right thank you
um for listening um yeah i'd
i think one of the counsellors last time
asked sort of how many
visitors do we get every year and to be
honest i can't really quantify it all i
know
that regularly every weekend we get four
or five visitors
so during the day i'm obviously not here
so i couldn't tell you how many during
the day
but if you take an average of four or
five visitors a day
it's sort of two or three hundred
visitors every year
um and they come from all over the world
and all over the country
i would ask members to think about the
monument
it's i i don't think there's many
monuments in the whole of
mid suffolk let alone the sort of the
wider suffolk
that has um a monument to a a national
english king and a saint um
it's maybe maybe it's lost in time
as to where he was martyred but this is
a reference point
within a field that people from all over
the country
come to visit that that enjoyment
and appreciation of the monument in its
setting is key not only to the village's
identity
but to english identity it's it's the
martyrdom
of someone that stood up for their their
beliefs
and was martyred and killed in open
space
this this development really does
impinge on that open space
at the moment the the reduction in sizes
is a a benefit but we still have
a development with an isolated property
now that's been
sort of drawn away from the other side
so it's an isolated
property now within the countryside of
over
three and a half thousand square feet it
is a huge monstrosity
and completely out of keeping out of
character
and in the wider scheme
and within sight of the
special landscape area completely
inappropriate
the the two sort of cottage
uh gatehouse type um properties
whilst it's it's a it's a welcome sort
of
addition uh as an architect i'd probably
prefer something a bit more contemporary
but it's a vernacular that is a
gatehouse
and by pairing two of the the gatehouses
together
it's a completely illogical and
unwelcome
topography of the way architectural
should be
if you're going to make a passage make
it a decent one
make it appropriate align it so it
appropriately aligns the approach
um to put two together um with chimneys
that are fake
it's just outrageous um and
inappropriate
and really destroys any of the
architectural sort of integrity of the
buildings themselves
um and unfortunately that including the
loss of the tree
excuse me um the time is up actually can
you please come up with one sentence
please
i think it's entirely inappropriate and
plot one is
is way too big for it's a very current
location
thank you very much uh mr marsh finally
do we have any questions for
from members please for mr martial
right okay um jamie you had a question
did you want to ask a question
uh not a question i just think it's
important to set out
um that mr marsh valley lives
yeah okay do we have any other questions
for for mr marshfield or for members
i've got one hand up and just try uh
come to the field please
yes just perhaps to ask you know say
this is the size of plot one is totally
inappropriate
how does it compare with other dwellings
in the area or
is it completely out of line
uh you ask me in height terms no
probably not
but in terms of scale of of footprint it
certainly is
and one that's isolated in the
countryside um
yeah you've got a good view of my house
there
and yes my my house was an original
bungalow that's very much like grasmere
and so i've increased the size
substantially one would argue so
in comparison to my house yes it's still
larger than my house
so um it's still quite a a thing in the
landscape
i'd like to think i've planted enough
trees around mine to not make it quite
so prominent and designed in a way that
is appropriate
to its location i think the problem is
is this bungalow
sits on its own in the middle of a
landscape um
and we'll sit out like a sore thumb
personally
thank you thank you thank you counselor
phil if we have no more questions
for mr rob marsh filey remembers
no thank you mr rob marshall f5 that's
very kind thank you very much
i'd like to know to ask the agent to
speak sarah roberts
sarah you have three minutes to address
the committee please i'll be grateful if
you could turn on your camera thank you
uh good morning um
the reason for refusal of the previous
reserve matters was
all about the design and scale of the
houses
those were the technical reasons for
refusing on the notice
um there were questions about why there
had to be four houses when the outline
of approval was
up to four and there were some neighbor
comments um
suggesting that um some reference should
be
made to local historic features within
other houses
within our new designs
so um in that sense the um
single story plot one will uh
blend in with the landscape um
the comments that were received on the
previous application
have all now been taken into account and
a continued
refusal will confirm that the members of
voting against the principle of
development
and seeking to prevent the outline
permission being implemented at all
in relation to the open space of
footpath we're open to any required
legal or conditional arrangement for the
future
ownership and management of the land
which can be decided
post approval it may be that the parish
wishes to apply for a formal
designation of the path as a public
right of way as well which is another
option open to them
final details of the preferred
arrangements and the land can be subject
to
a condition and certainly we would
open discussions with the parish council
which don't need to be rushed
um the issue of the um
of the post-rail fence is optional as
well
and there's the finishing of the
footpath and i i would see it as
a as a managed green sway that could
have
um some um mesh underneath it
for winter access that kind of thing so
we don't do anything
we've received compliments from um
members of the hobson community on the
current designs um and the proposal will
be low-key
and sensitive infill scheme on this it
is an unusual site we accept that
um and if the community wishes to take
the
control of the otherwise if the
community doesn't wish to
take control of it then it will be
managed the larger part of it will be
managed by
a management company for the residents
the the immediate residents
um
there was that there's any i ash died
back but
the ash tree is about a meter in the
wrong position
for a double um entrance so
that will be replaced with a with a with
another one
so that's um sorry to interrupt uh so
that the time is actually up can you
just sign up
thanks thank you very much sarah um we
have questions
from councillor mansell please first
uh thank you chair i'd just like some
clarification i'm not sure if um
mrs roberts is the person to answer the
question but it relates to the footpath
in our recommendations on page 271
it appears that it's a section 106 that
that will become a public right-of-way
um but other parts of the document refer
to it as being a permissive
path could we have some clarity about
whether this path
will become a public right-of-way or is
it just a permissive path
the um there is a the process
is that a public right-of-way has to be
applied for
it's not the the planning process can't
uh designate it as a public right-of-way
as i understand it
so but as i say we're open to any
any options on the on the final
designation
of the land which is being allocated as
the view to the monument
perhaps i could also come in the chair
if you wouldn't mind
sorry oh jamie yes jesus come in jamie
please thank you yeah
the the terms in terms of the permissive
path is what's existing
uh we will be securing this whole area
as part of an open space
uh public open space and therefore
public can cross over this area
uh as the agency
um
yes of course apologies i didn't realize
my microphone i must have moved it up
apologies so just
not in a shed no yeah so just to
reaffirm that
the section 106 will secure this whole
area as a public open space
that public open space includes that
path and therefore public can walk
across that path
the public making it a public right of
way uh probably would be a good idea but
that is a subsequent application with
suffolk county council
and sits outside of the planning part of
it so the section 106 will control it as
a public open space therefore
public can walk across this area our
point of the fence is to try and direct
them through here
rather than walking on this area here i
would add in terms of the public benefit
part of things
we can only secure it up to this line
there is a section here
that is not included which is in other
ownership and therefore it's up to
members to decide how much
benefit they provide to that but
securing this area
is better than what it currently is as a
permissive path where a farmer could
just
put a hedge across there and stop people
walking can i
can can i come back on that because that
to me
uh contradicts um item one
in the recommendation on page 271 which
quite clearly has a bullet point that
says
public right of way so is it either is a
public right-of-way
or it's just a public open space but i
think that um
maybe that first item on the
recommendation
needs uh to be a bit clearer now i
agree with that that's my fault uh
counselor mansoor i think uh
in terms of trying to write a report to
say uh is a public path would have
probably been a better way of doing it
rather than the term public right of way
which obviously conflicts with what
is a definition by suffolk county
council means apologies
thank you very much uh uh councillor
mansell
um councillor stringer please thank
thank you chair uh yes obviously uh
we're in quite a sensitive location
uh given the special landscape area can
can someone actually uh confirm to me
which design guide we were using to
actually
include what is essentially fake
chimneys
surely the architectural design here
there should be more integrity than this
so so come and explain
what which design guide we're using for
that
we don't actually have a design guide um
for mid-suffolk we i know that the
suffolk design guide
panel was a thing prior to us going into
covid
i'm not aware of any of those workshops
continuing i know that there was a
county-wide
design document that was being
accumulated but we haven't seen any
drafts of that we haven't seen anything
so at the moment there is no design
guide my understanding and perhaps the
agent might be able to answer this
better but the idea of these two houses
came as a result of the objections that
were submitted on the last application
indicating a particular house in the
area that might be of uh
architectural merit that we could look
towards using
i have to admit uh dealing with an
application recently in the woolpit area
i'm not
particularly fond of fake chimneys
however in this context we obviously
don't want to be using carbon footprints
and fireplaces
but at the same time architectural notes
of
a chimney itself provides a bit of a
traditional character
um so i see no harm in doing that
thank you
okay to the field sorry can i come back
on sorry yes sir
obviously there is a carbon footprint to
producing something that's inherently a
fake
and it lacks integrity um
you know we might as well just have
plastic columns then and everything else
if the member felt that they were happy
to approve the application without the
chimneys and notwithstanding
condition could be put onto the
application to remove those
thank you okay
do we have any more questions from
councillors
council of field yeah is it a question
i i was just going to suggest perhaps to
jamie that you can clearly we could
undertake to make the application to
suffolk county council for the right of
way
since this path has been in use for a
number of years might have suggest that
we make that
right up to the monument uh because you
know
if if a path has been used and i can't
remember
it's eight years or longer but if it has
been used and you can prove it for a
number of years
it doesn't matter what the landowner
thinks to be blunt you can
you can make it a public right of way
i have to admit i'm not reverse uh
rehearsed in in
public right of way legislation and
therefore i would leave it up to
obviously our suffer county council
colleagues to make that judgment and
what evidence they would require
uh from a planning perspective it's
different ownership and
therefore our planning control can't
look after this area we could add a note
or something
yeah an informative definitely i think
that that would be an appropriate way
forward
okay do we have any more questions at
all
for for the agent
no then i would like to ask the ward
member councillor matthew hicks to speak
please
thank you very much mr chairman um so
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak i think this is the fourth
application i've ever called in in my
nine years as
a district councillor and the reason for
that is due to the
impact this has i think we need to just
bear in mind that this is an
anciently established village
and it's actually made up of two
villages heckfield green and cross
street
and there is a permissive footpath that
runs across the site
that's heading to this monument and this
monument
let's not let's not uh you know
underestimate the importance to
nationally not just locally but
nationally
of what it's remembering it's
remembering that in 869
a.d king edmund was martyred and rumored
to
or likely to have been actually um shot
to death
uh with arrows while tied to a tree
so um this is really a a
really historic important sight that
is part of the identity of hoxson and
the area
and every year i don't know if any of
you have the opportunity to drive
through hoxton or in the vicinity
but on the 20th of november uh local
residents certainly did process through
the village to commemorate his life
and anyone that would have driven
through the area would have seen the
flag of saint edmund
flying over gate posts in fact
everywhere
probably competing with this nhs nhs
rainbows so
it is you know locally it's extremely
important but i would argue nationally
and to some degree you could go as far
as internationally
so um so hoxton is really a clearly well
known
uh well well-represented ancient uh
community
uh and is very proud of that history i
think um just a couple of points i'd
like to dwell on is
um if we look at the reserved matters
application
uh they came forward the uh the 05
double eight and the 101 717
and you before had an opportunity to
look at that and came to a conclusion
uh actually that you weren't satisfied
and you weren't satisfied because uh
basically the design and scale
was not appropriate the architect
applicant has just said that
if you don't support it you're going i
think against the outline planning
application
no i think the reason that one shouldn't
support this is because the design
appearance layout scale landscape and
quality
is not fitting for the location that
it's being put in
just because we have gone away from the
last meeting and made changes
does not mean it is right the changes
have been done but in my view are still
unacceptable um i have had no positive
comments and no positive emails
from anyone in the community uh i go to
parish councils i
do occasionally when i can go to the pub
or that has been more difficult
obviously during lockdown
um and and i have not had anyone say to
me that they see this as a positive
influence on the community um i think
it's really sad that
we have an ash tree that is just being
dismissed out of hand i know if it was
an oak tree there'd be
uh far more um action to try and save it
but an ash tree that is healthy is not a
frequent occurrence in mid-suffolk
certainly around me unfortunately there
are many ash trees with significant die
back so
i've just asked members to weigh that up
when they
come to make a consideration um
the two proposed accesses of course were
not what was approved before
uh that's not what is in the outline
planning permission so i would ask you
to weigh
up whether moving these is actually
changing the application significantly
and i would argue
that by taking a tree impacting a tree
that is changing it
very significantly um i'd also ask you
to consider around the
uh the houses that are being proposed uh
the lodge cottages as we've heard them
described as
um are they fitting for this location do
they fit in
um or are we urbanizing what is
effectively
a very rural part of the town um
is it appropriate to have this sort of
housing in front of
a uh a monument celebrating an
ancient location and i'd ask members to
consider that
in terms of scale i take you to the
email
that has been is in the pack from paul
harrison who says in mppf terms
harm arising from the proposal is
reduced from the level resulting from
the previous proposal
but is not eliminated in my view the
improvements in the proposal should be
regarded as reducing or avoiding harm
but in heritage terms would not qualify
as benefits
over and above so actually
and that could be weighed up in the
planning balance so actually
i don't think we are getting unanimous
support from paul harrison
our heritage officer and the paper is
for you to read in the pack
so i think i would present that
differently to the way the case officer
has described that
so the development in summary really is
one of the most significant sites it
is actually bringing two separate
villages together
and is that appropriate in this location
now we have an outline
so that is therefore agreed but what we
therefore need to think about
is what is appropriate in terms of the
built environment what is appropriate
for this location what is appropriate in
terms of scale and size
and what impact does that have on
on and relevance to this location
so members this is a difficult one but i
have to say i think it's really
important
we continue to protect enhance uh
our natural and historic environment i
think the
application before us does not do that
and therefore i would ask you to
consider
about the importance of rejecting this
application because i do believe it
contravenes the mppf
particularly around the environmental
objectives
which does talk about contributing and
protecting
and enhancing our natural built in
historic environment
and to me this does not tick that box
thank you members thank you thank you
occasionally hicks do we have any
questions for councillor hicks
please
all right we have one hand up and that
is for
cancer stringer please sorry catch the
mayor first thank you
thank you chair um the board member
emphasizes how important the
monument is um can you tell me has the
parish council invested any money
assets or time in enhancing that that
monument for example information boards
or anything of that kind
i'm fred i've only been the member for
hoxson
since may uh and since then i'm not
aware of
expenditure um but the parish council
i'm sure can answer that because i'm
there will be something but i couldn't
tell you what it's been spent on having
not um
been seen the accounts but if you want
i'm sure
if the parish clerk's online she could
answer that
i think that will be useful if the
parish clark's there please yeah
absolutely if you'd like me to i'd be
more than
pleased um i don't know if jamie's photo
will scale in enough but each of those
um wooden posts has got intricate
carvings
wooden post jamie and i don't know if
that's an old photo but each of those
four posts it's got intricate carvings
representing
um elements of the history of an edmond
that one of them's got an acorn on
um one of them's got a dagger on et
cetera et etc
um we talk about money it's volunteer
time
um what maybe rather than actual
physical money going out of the parish
council's public
funds to maintain the monument a lot of
this is done by volunteer time
um yes in terms of tourism and
representing the history of the site
there's the hoxon heritage walk which
has got information boards there's an
information board at the bottom
of the steps on the entrance up to the
monument
and there's accompanying leaflets which
you often see people walking around the
village
with that are in containers at the
village hall car park and
in the church and the village hall car
park is not far away at all just down
the road beyond the cyclist and on the
left
um so is it was it financial commitment
from the parish council to the monument
and what
the um what it spent on promoting its
heritage wasn't it was that the two
questions
absolutely very useful thank you very
useful thank you thank you very much
you're welcome you can see the
information board there jamie that's it
yeah there
yeah thank you very much sir um do you
have any sort of um
other questions sir councillor mayor no
does anybody else have any other
questions for uh councillor hicks please
no in that case then we move to debate
who would like to kick off the debate
nobody right let's look at the list of
names
um right i'm not sure quite sure who was
first
uh councillor manson were you
i wasn't deliberately trying to be first
i was trying to hold off but nobody else
seemed to be willing
um i i think we're in a very unfortunate
position here because
we've got the outline planning
permission which was granted a few years
ago
for up to four dwellings now
what i don't like i don't particularly
like the design
of of the dwellings that we've got here
i certainly don't like fake chimneys i'm
i'm with council stringer all the way
there
what is the point of making something
look like something it's not
um these houses are huge
they are big bungalows uh even if the
plots two and three are two-bedroom
bungalows they are big two-bedroom
bungalows
and they are they are going to be uh you
know
significant in in the landscape of going
to the
you know when you go to visit the
monument um
but having said that i'm not an
architect
and i have no idea what we would find
to be acceptable on this site and it's
already got
outline planning permission and that's
what i find quite difficult
this this i think it is a bit of an impr
it's certainly better to only have three
dwellings rather than the four um
but i'm still not convinced that we've
got
that much benefit we're losing a tree
um and with regards to the open space
i think you know that that's a sort of
token in the right direction
um if if this does get permission um
i'd i really hope the parish council can
take it on i i think
if it is such an important part of the
um historic
you know business of hoxson i think it
would be in their interests
to take take that on i'm certainly not
convinced by a post and rail fence
um with the open meadow i i personally i
think i prefer just to see a moan path
up there but of course i don't come by
car
so i hadn't occurred to me that people
would park
and try and sneak across diagonally from
the
public right away entrance to from the
road um
because of course i just plunked the
bike by the pavement and walk up the
path in the middle and
sorry i wasn't appreciating that but um
i i still i just i really don't know
what to think about this i don't like it
but we've got the outline planning
permission um and having listened to the
objector and i think it was the parish
council
uh saying that that plot one uh sort of
is now completely dissociated from the
rest of the environment around there i i
tend to agree with that
but then we've got this plot we want to
have the space in the middle
so that we can still still have view of
the monument
um we've got we meant to we've got up to
four houses on here i'm not
convinced of how we could get four
houses on there
and not create other problems so i will
listen to what other people say but i
don't particularly like this application
but we are where we are with the outline
uh something is going to get built on
that site and and is this
as good as we're going to get or should
we hold out for something better i don't
know
i'll i'll listen and and take on board
other people's views
thank you caitlyn councillor matheson
then councillor stringer then councillor
mayor please
thank you chair yeah the
what i'm asking myself really is what is
that what is a
an appeal inspector going to say about
this
um that that is the problem really
um something that's that's offering a
reduction
from from the outline from from four to
three
and uh obviously a considerable
reduction in the um
living square meterage uh albeit they're
quite big bungalows
nevertheless having taken off a top
story and so on
um it is clearly quite a big reduction
it's it's i think really quite
hard to justify refusal
um because it's so hard to envisage what
what could be done
that would would respect the the fact
that there is an outline
permission for up to four it's it is
extraordinarily difficult to
see your way around that really i think
as far as the tree is concerned
um the the
oh i've lost it oh okay sorry let's come
back
um yeah as far as the tree's concerned
the
the canopy spread and
therefore the root spread of the tree
that was there
if you then apply that spread in due
course
uh the roots the roots are going to go
underneath the
the driveway anyway in due course
so i just wonder what the point of
cutting the tree down actually is
um it's it's hard to see i don't know
quite whether it's
highways or or who is that says that
in order to achieve it a two dwelling
access um it needs to be
that wide and the tree's got to go i
don't i don't know where the
the requirement for that is actually
coming from and as i say if you put
another tree in its place
so close it will finish up nearly the
same
which might be nice in one way but in
another way what was the
what was the point of cutting the first
one down really so
i think i think it's it's difficult to
refuse
so let's hear what others have got to
say for a bit thank you councilman
could i just uh bring in um jamie please
just before councillor stringer
thank you chair uh yeah two things i
just wanted to put in there uh
firstly councilman matheson just in
regards to their access for it to serve
one plot it needs to be 3.5 meters wide
for it to serve to
4.5 for memory uh so
yeah that the wider one would encroach
right on that trunk of that tree
and hence it needs to be if if it is
approved and we have one access
serving the two plots it needs to come
out to be able to accommodate that
uh in regards to this is not necessarily
a material consideration but i think
it's a good idea for counselors to be
aware
the outline application has run out uh
the application for reserve matters was
validated two days before
if this application is refused they
cannot
resubmit an application um for reserve
matters
however both the scheme that was refused
in august
and this scheme can both be appealed and
simultaneously jamie just to check when
did it expire with the new
extensions to may next year don't forget
uh that's very true apologies thank you
thank you
uh gemma so uh yes it would actually
uh go up to march uh is it the 31st
uh first of may i think next year sorry
apologies yes no it would
that's 100 correct um because of the the
new extensions due to
the covid any extent planning
permissions did get an extension as per
the government guidelines so
uh yeah apologies i stand corrected to
that oh that's fine
only because we happened to cross over
that in training yes
yesterday right if you think so no
problem
okay thank you jamie um stringer
counselor mayor then councillor field
please
thank you chair uh this is indeed uh
another one that's
incredibly naughty and twisty uh so what
i tend to do is go back to first
principles to see
to try and get some clarity we have a
site
that has an outline approval
we have a site that has a refusal that's
within a
time limit for appeal and we have a
second
go at this we also have a site that's
inside the
draft joint local plan and the second
draft joint local plan
so the likelihood of development on this
site is relatively strong
so where we're into then is
uh is design and
consequences and what it is that we're
trying to achieve
um i really really wish we could roll
back time
uh to when we had a five-year land
supply and the consequences of not
having one weren't rigged on our
countryside
uh but we can't do that here
what what i need to try and do is do as
best as i can do
to do justice to the history of the site
so when we look at the history of the
site we have a monument to a fallen
tree and i think what we don't want to
do now is have a
load of houses that are a monument to a
fallen tree
uh the monument we have there at the
moment i believe is 1908
because the original one got damaged
it's so you know it it's actually got i
only got the wrong date on it but never
mind
uh it was 1848 i believe that the oak
tree fell anyway it doesn't matter
although history is very important i
think we we have an extent we have a
permission
that says up to four we had a very
inappropriate development which we
refused which could still be appealed
we now have another uh proposal here
which frankly
uh you know i still think's barking up
the wrong tree
design wise but of course the outline
didn't help us because it didn't say
thou shalt build a you know contemporary
looking design or a pastiche or whatever
it said
we are also next we've got a mixture of
houses around it that don't have a
clearly defined type
we've got everything from almost sort of
local authority housing to ancient
thatched housing to bungalows as well so
it it's not it's not that clear
so from my mind i'm actually still quite
torn about this
because my fear is if this is refused we
will end up with
an appeal on both of them uh
and we could then end up with the really
inappropriate one we could
approve this one of course and still get
an appeal on on the
original four so uh as i i have to say i
mean a real binder because i don't think
this is good enough
i also think the scale of it is also
something quite interesting
if you impose minimum space standards
one bungalow alone on this site
could be the same footprint as three
three-bedroom terraced houses
so you know these are these are quite
good but then
something in a wonderful historic
landscape
probably should have a you know a very
luxurious house so there is that there
is that that tear and i really have not
made my mind up
do i think this is good enough for me to
approve no
is it bad enough for me to refuse not
sure
sorry i can't be any more help chair
thank you very much sir counterstringer
oh councillor mayor please
thanks joe um
it's better but is it good enough
the i for me there are four issues here
firstly plot one
council believe it is a very large house
the objector
believes it's too large and yet we've
got suffolk preservation
that are happy to accept it
then we can move down to design
well for me the biggest part of poor
design
is the fact that the access to the
monument is so poor
we have an open space that you can't
walk across you have to use a footpath
you can't and yet there are other access
points that won't
link together that don't link together
so for me
the poor design is actually that the
monument hasn't taken
pride of place design access to the
monument
and then add the buildings on top i
don't think
that's the case the tree
yes it will be a sad loss
but if it keeps the access down to
manageable
um configuration then i'll accept
that and the fake chimneys well
i think the less said about those the
better they they don't add
any value and really have no part in a
a good scheme going forward
i was very interested to hear what
council stringer said
and we are
on the horns of a dilemma we used that
in a previous
um application but do we approve
something because it's better
i'm i'm inclined to stick to your guns
and say no
the design around access to the monument
is not good enough
and that for me is enough to
uh to say that i don't think i will be
supporting this skill
thank you casey bear case the field
please
yes i think council stringer did a good
analysis
um
one's question really is could we get
anything better we have a bit of a
history at the moment of rejecting
things and
finding a scheme that actually improves
with time
but i have to say i don't find this
particularly unacceptable
it does give access to a monument
as councillor stringer said a monument
that dates back
all the way to 1840 not quite all the
way back to some edmonds
because i believe if i read correctly
that the abbey that used to exist around
oxen
didn't actually accept that he was
killed in this area
but nevertheless it's a monument it's
there it's been there for
hundreds or so years and it obviously
attracts
tourists so it's it's perhaps worth
preserving
we are improving access to it we can
have a public right of way
um you might even extend that all the
way to the monument
itself and certainly there's a a public
open space which is
a benefit when i look at the houses um
certainly is it's an improvement on the
previous scheme
um the two are fairly small
totally agree with the point that uh
plastic chimneys aren't appropriate but
the house designs are reasonable
in their context the larger one
i'm not convinced it's that amount
bigger than
than the um the objectors dwelling
um and i personally don't feel a moral
need to ensure houses are always smaller
than my own or whatever
the criteria is that people tend to use
you know
you need a variety of house sizes to
support um
an active economy um some some for
people in
uh basic jobs some some for for their
leaders
so having a variety of house size seems
appropriate and
suitable to the economy um
and say we do retain
uh visual contact with the monument
and not from everywhere but it seems to
be
very similar to what it is at the moment
so i think in on balance um
i'm in favor of this scheme
with slight thoughts that uh could we
achieve
something even better if we tried
i'm inclined to think the answer to
that's probably not
so i'm
yeah sort of in favor i guess thank you
coachella field counselor hanging him
please
thank you um like um
frankly i agree with almost everything
that everyone said earlier
and this is a really tricky one i'd say
it definitely is an
improvement on the last one but what i
don't really like is the fact that um
site one does cut from what i feel is
the best view is you come
before this corner where jamie basically
said we're losing this view but we've
still got this one
i feel that you're more on the corner if
you are in the car
by the time you get into the corner
you're looking at the road rather than
thinking where's the monument and so i
feel that you are losing what probably
is the best of you but like i said it is
an
improvement but like matthew i took that
paul harrison was not sort of saying oh
yes now it's brilliant no harm
he was definitely saying the harm is
reduced but not eliminated
and yet like rick says um the suffolk
preservation society seem to think it's
okay
and so you know we are in a in a bind
here people and
like we've all said you know we don't
like it but we haven't got enough to
refuse it so um
yeah i'm stuck thank you okay thank you
for having me counselor mayor did you
wish to come back please
um just a question really i mean much of
my concern about the design about access
to the monument
will be alleviated if if the post and
rail fence were removed from the path
and then the path actually split into
three so that you could actually
enter the site through any of the
driveways or the bottom of the path
is that something we could um condition
jamie could you come in there please yes
of course um i think in terms of the
existing
uh circumstances on site the the route
from
from here to here is technically the
only route that should be taken to the
monument
i think because of the low scale area
here and people
parking here i think people are just
walking across there
i would be concerned of asking
pedestrians to use those sites however
i do hear that we if we just took this
post rail out
it means that people aren't contained
within a path
the risk there is do they come up the
stairs and walk all across here well if
we're going to have it as a public open
space
why can't they i guess i was trying to
protect the area as a wildflower
designation of not designation but a
wildflower meadow
so we didn't have people trampling
across flowers that we're trying to grow
and
enhance kind of you know bees coming to
the area and things like that
but yeah i'm open to that i think the
developer would be as well we're not
withstanding condition to remove this
post and rail
and perhaps a close boarded fence in
this area here might be appropriate too
to add on
um but yeah yeah i don't see any issues
in removing that poster rail as part of
a notwithstanding condition
okay thank you jamie uh councillor mate
did you wish to come back on that at all
no thank you no thank you okay lavinia
do you have oh
no everyone's i'd like to uh make a few
comments myself if i may please
i think counselor hattingham you made a
very good point about what the suffolk
preservation society says
and paragraph 8.18 clarifies that
and i quote going further the suffolk
preservation society consider
that the new scheme by the adoption of a
strong landscape led layout
the reduction in dwellings from four to
three securing views to the monument and
introduction of an open space
with metal style planting will
cumulatively
enhance the setting of the heritage
assets
and the other comment that i
particularly picked up on was on page
256
and i quote again design treatment of
units two and three
no relates to the design of the
single-story lodge buildings associated
with the former
oakley park stroke hoxson hall which
stand just outside hoxson
on approach roads in my view this is the
obviously the planning office view in my
view this design treatment will
contribute
to local distinctiveness the design
treatment of unit 1 uses a range of
materials and forms familiar
in agricultural buildings within the
district
however he goes on to say i believe the
proposed layout will not answer members
concerns
about the opportunity to appreciate the
monument as approached along abby hill
to the north west of the site as unit 1
is likely to foil views at several
points
with a clear view only becoming
available
near the access to down bridge so at the
moment i must admit i
am still sort of sitting on the fence on
this one it is a really sort of
complicated
um application but we've heard some very
good views on that
i'd just like to open it up to members
again for any
comment further comments or whether
somebody wishes to um propose um
the application and second it councillor
matheson please
yeah i think uh i i'm actually going to
propose
approval having heard what office have
said about the the risks of appeals
and what suffolk preservation society
have said
i mean i cannot see
how we i mean i understand that the
point about the two settlements
and and the fact that that plot number
one is is
doing its best to actually bring those
two together
um but unfortunately i can't see any way
in which one could put
more than two uh dwellings onto the
other half
of this site and and leave that's that
side of the um
of the of the site empty of
of development um you know desirable as
that might be
we we would you know we would lose our
appeal
if we tried to reduce it to two or
whatever
uh so i i can't see you know
i think that it's better to take this
one and then
probably the the applicant won't want to
um try and appeal the the horrible
one that we refused already um so i you
know
at least worse way forward really
propose approval
thank you very much casey matherson um
council of field
please i'd be happy to second that i
think if happy is the right word
um i certainly am inclined to say even
looking at that
photo of the mon monument it's pretty
remote
i would just suggested that the
important thing is where
you can walk up and contemplate the
monument
and think of the the issues that
occurred in
in ancient history and uh how primitive
things were at that time
um so you know i i and i think uh
cows and masters and analyzed it
properly i'll stop there but i'll second
it
thank you very much catch the field
council stringer please
yeah thank you chair uh now we have a
proposal could i could i ask the
proposer and secretary to consider
despite the the the design cue
removing those fake chimneys and
actually exploring uh
i can hear what the officer was saying
he didn't want the he wanted the
entrance
the walking entrance and the currents to
be quite distinct
but of course we then lose a perfectly
good tree uh
i really don't see how we couldn't
actually join all of those three
entrances together
uh to form a decent entrance yes you'll
have a confluence of cars and
pedestrians
but you know i'm sure a few people at
the weekend can avoid whatever cars are
going to be coming in and out of here
where then you can actually save the
tree i really think we should explore
all avenues to save that tree
if it means that we have either a
slightly substandard entrance
or that we we join those together to
avoid losing it i think we should pursue
that
thank you chair thank you okay uh jamie
would you like to come back in again
please
yeah thank you very much chair um whilst
i'm confident that we can
get away uh with the chimneys and
the post and rail fencing via condition
uh
based on the type of application that
we're looking at and
i i don't see that we'd be able to
approve an application and condition it
to say that the accesses need to be
changed
and the pedestrian access to to
amalgamate into one or an alternative
solution for them to come up with
uh i i think that if if that was a real
sticking point
it would need to be down as a reason for
refusal and the application refused and
for them to come back in
and readdress that i don't think that
would be reasonable to condition such a
thing in that instance
okay thank you councillor matheson
please yeah i'm
i mean i'm interested in what council
string is saying there
would that be then that we put the three
entrances basically where the steps are
at the moment
and and lower the um lower the view
um you know the bank that the steps go
up
um so and then then the two driveways
diverge
um is that is that the sort of thing you
you're talking about i mean i can see
the
point of it and as i've i've said
already that the
the the removal of the trees is pretty
farcical really
i think if you wouldn't mind you if i if
i just um provide a little bit more
detail
um the steps are currently located here
exactly where that
um path is right at the bottom here so i
think if we had accumulated
an access that came into here and an
access that came into here and we opened
this right up so we've got an access for
for both cars and pedestrians i think
this ashtray is going to have to go
so those accesses and the path are all
going to have to come around into this
access here
i have to admit that i wrote in my
report that i think the real
unveiling of this monument where it's
dead in front of you is when you get to
the top of those stairs
and i think changing this pedestrian
access here
um in my eyes would not be a
good thing to do in terms of the
unveiling of that monument
and again i will reiterate that if we
want to have a look at changing these
accesses
uh and and have it amalgamated we need
to have that as a reason for refusing
and go back to the drawing board which
they have that extension until
may to do so but um yeah i'll leave that
up to the rest of the debate thank you
thank you very much thank you uh catch
the field please as i say i
i think that uh our argument from jamie
holds a lot of water i did as i stopped
talking realized that i'd failed to say
anything about the post and rail fences
which i certainly think
should go um
as to the ash tree
trees are valuable they exist like the
one that's in everyone's tied to they do
disappear in time and
planting new ones uh continue ensures
that
we have a continuation like for a long
period
i therefore feel that i'm not that
concerned about taking down an ash which
do
does suffer from ash dieback now and
replacing it um yeah so
yeah i'll go with the under removal of
the plastic chimneys i think
so plastic chimneys and posts and rails
are out
um replacement trees that i
personally find fairly relaxed about
thank you very much councillor matterson
please
yeah um yeah as the proposal
could i perhaps i just run through the
the adjustments that we've got to the
recommendation
as far as i can see at the moment the
first one was to to amend
the um the 106 so that it's
it's talking about the the public path
that leads through the site towards the
monument or something like that
um and then um that we we're not having
those fences
and we're not having any extra stories
stuck on the bungalows
and we're not having any plastic
chimneys and if council feels
agreeable on all that a lot
thank you yeah um therefore if we've got
no other
um comments from members can i now
ask the chief planning officer area
planning manager to read out the
proposal on the table for
before we go to a vote please uh over to
you gemma thank you
sorry apologies to interrupt um uh can i
just
state uh i it was a bit of an
afterthought when there was lots of
conversation about fencing
this particular area of fencing here is
close boarded and perhaps
being in the street scene might be
considered a bit of an urbanization here
and perhaps this should be seen as
an extra condition to remove this and
have it as a hedgerow instead of
of close boarded fencing but only
because of the amount of conversation
around fencing that's taken place i
thought i'd put that forward which is i
said earlier
well so far i suggest that we uh by
it's very much a bullet point to jamie
you can take that away and sort out the
wording but that i would suggest
so we've got the recommendations it
stands on page 271 to 272
and then the addition of conditions so
details of the path
surface to be agreed with removal of the
fencing along the permissive pathway and
i'll add and details to be agreed so
that that leaves it open to jamie
if you you know can agree on a
replacement for that close boarded
fencing
or if it still needs some degree of
fencing we've got that
option to go and work on that under the
condition
then we'd remove permitted development
rights under class aaa for additional
stories i take it that was just that was
the only
pd we were looking at removing so that's
what i've suggested
then uh notwithstanding the details
submitted the chimneys
are not included on the on the approval
um
and finally yes the section 106 that
mentions
um public right of way should in fact um
state public open space and pathway
rather than right of way
okay thank you sure could i just ask
officers what's the purpose of the of
the close boarded fence
on plot um two
it's uh to provide um screening
obviously to their their
rear garden area in terms of an amenity
and previously yeah so a hedge would do
just as well
yes i mean it would take a little bit
longer to form but yes
i would agree a hedgerow here would
probably be more appropriate in terms of
the street scene setting
okay well i i'd i'd agree with that then
if council of field agrees with that
totally this isn't this is not an area
where you're going to get
shed loads of pedestrians gazing in so
there's time i'll suggest for a hitch to
grow
okay thank you very much indeed
everybody i will now ask
the governor's office to conduct the
roll call or the electronic vote please
thank you chair so if members could
please go to
the modern.gov app and in the same way
as previously go to the
voting tab under the plus sign where i
will now
start the vote
[Music]
[Music]
so
thank you members so i can confirm that
the vote is
six votes for with one against so thank
you
thank you very much indeed thank you um
not the final question do any site
inspection requests need to be reported
to the committee
no chair no thank you very much in that
case i'd like to thank everyone that's
taken part in this morning's
debates on the three applications we've
decided and i therefore close the
meeting at 13
20.